foreign
course on RPA UI path this full course
video will cover the core topics of RPA
UI path RPA is in demand and highly
growing field uipath is a leading
robotic process automation tool for
large scale end-to-end automation for an
accelerated business change it provides
solution for business to automate growth
in office activities
so if you are interested in RPA and
tools like uipath then you're in the
right place
this video will help you understand the
concepts of RPA UI path so here is the
list of topics covered
we'll first understand what is RPA
then look at the top 10 reasons to learn
robotic process automation we will see
some of the real-time RPA examples
followed by which we will look at the
comparison between RPA tools like uipath
automation anywhere and blue prism
proceeding further we will understand
what is uipath and then learn how uipath
is installed in the device
then we will see the UI part tutorial
for beginners followed by which we will
go through uipath orchestrator uipath
robotic Enterprise framework uipath web
Automation and then we will see Excel
Automation in uipath as to how Excel is
used in uipath lastly we will see RPA
developer salaries skills resume roles
and responsibilities and finally uipath
interview questions that will help you
crack the interview with ease
I'm sure you are excited to begin with
full course
but before we begin make sure you have
subscribed to our YouTube channel and
click down the Bell icon so you never
miss an update from Simply learn
so without wasting any further time
let's get started
this is Jim he is an accountant in a
multinational company he handles several
invoices and other Financial records
like monetary transactions liabilities
checks and ledgers on a daily basis one
of his tasks is to copy all the relevant
information from these invoices such as
the name of the company invoice ID and
data processing into a spreadsheet and
mail the sheet along with other
Financial reports to a superiors by the
end of the day as any prompt employee he
transfers all the information to the
sheet attaches the reports and sends
them over to his boss via email every
day but over a period he starts finding
this task to be time consuming and
repetitive frustrated Jim looks for a
way to reduce the time and effort it
takes to complete the task and voila he
stumbles across robotic process
automation AKA RPA using robotic process
automation he builds a simple bot that
extracts information from several
invoices into an Excel sheet attaches
all the necessary Financial reports and
sends them over to his superiors via
email at a specific time every day so
what exactly is robotic process
automation robotic process automation
RPA is the use of software with
artificial intelligence and machine
learning capabilities to handle high
volume repetitive tasks that previously
required humans to perform some of these
tasks include addressing queries making
calculations maintenance of records and
Performing transactions there are
several misconceptions about RPA RPA is
not a humanoid robot it does not have a
physical form and no resemblance to
humans RPA cannot replace humans or
replicate human cognitive functions it
does not have a brain of its own and
cannot perform logical or critical
thinking as humans do the working of RPA
includes four crucial phases one the
planning phase typically involves
Gathering the processes to be automated
identifying the test objects and
finalizing the implementation approach
2. the development phase includes the
creation of automation workflows as per
the agreed Plan Three deployment and
testing is a vital phase since it
uncovers any unexpected outages and
ensures a bug-free product 4. lastly
there's the support and maintenance
phase which ensures that the product is
continuously updated with smooth
deployment across the user base to meet
the objectives of RPA tools are used
these RPA tools are software
applications that can configure tasks
and automate them some of the popular
RPA tools in the market are uipath
automation anywhere blue prism work
Fusion Pega and Redwood among others
when it comes to Quality RPA ensures
consistent error-free output leading to
reduced operational risks this in turn
improves customer satisfaction in the
area of delivery RPA can help decrease
the average handling time and this
enhances the customer experience and
ensures 24 7 business continuity with
respect to cost according to nascom
domestic businesses can reduce the cost
by up to 65 percent through RPA it
offers a higher Roi by driving positive
returns within quarters as opposed to
years other advantages of RPA include
reduced training costs minimal
utilization of it resources and easier
software migration today many domains
and industries like Banking and finance
it integration processes Human Resources
insurance agencies marketing and sales
and customer relationship management
readily deploy RPA RPA service adoption
has been showing tremendous growth since
2016 and will continue to increase
Beyond 2020. according to mckinsey's
research knowledge and work automation
could have an economic impact of five to
seven trillion dollars by the year 2025.
it will impact more than 230 million
knowledge workers which constitute nine
percent of the global Workforce
any company which is labor intensive
where people are performing high volume
High transaction functions stand to
benefit the most with RPA adoption
boosting their capabilities and saving
money and time
now that we've discussed what RPA is and
isn't here's a question for you which of
the following is not an RPA use case one
email query processing two data
extraction three image recognition
4. payroll processing
give it a thought and leave your answers
in the comments section below RPA offers
the ability to automate business
processes quickly and easily it paves
the way for digital transformation by
placing automation tools at the user's
disposal so what are you waiting for get
certified and become an RPA developer to
build a bright future in the field of
automation 10 reasons why you should
learn RPA
but before jumping into it
now do you remember the time you used
the digital calculator it may be your
Calculus class
it made it so much easier for you to
arrive at an answer
calculators undoubtedly help you solve
complex mathematical problems which
previously required a lot of time
and of course doing manual calculations
have inherently several errors
but does calculation account for
automation
well no a conventional calculator
requires manual input so this is partial
automation
automating the usage of a calculator
that requires zero human intervention is
what RPA does
so what exactly is RPA
robotic process automation is the use of
software with artificial intelligence
and machine learning capabilities to
handle high volume repeated tasks that
previously required humans
now some of these tasks include
addressing queries making calculations
maintaining records or even making
transactions
so why is RPA gaining popularity so
rapidly and why do companies and techies
have RPA perspectives
so here are the 10 reasons why one
should learn RPA
so number 10 fast implementation
now getting data entry Bots up and
running goes quickly implementing a new
RPA Software System certainly happens
much faster than training a new person
you can have these data entry Bots up
and running in just days
in contrast if you wanted to hire a new
human employee you'd be taking a lot of
time and sorting out resumes conducting
interviews going through the entire
boring hiring process and then finally
when you find the right person you'd
have to spend time and energy on
training them
however in case of RPA all of this is
countered
and number nine we have no training time
so now this is an important one
if your process changes and the Bots
need to learn something new you can
either replace them with new Bots or
alter their programming
now that again goes much faster than
training employees for new tasks in
terms of costs training an employee for
a new task will pan out to be way more
expensive and time consuming
next up the Bots will never quit
now with RPA you don't have to worry
about employees quitting or dealing with
a turnover
Bots don't care how hard they're working
or how boring their job is or how
repeatedly they're doing the same tasks
again yes it would be ironic if the Bots
got tired
software Bots can work all the time 24
hours a day every single day of the year
at 100 capacity now RPA doesn't take
holidays it doesn't have sick needs and
of course they do not have unproductive
days at all
well isn't that a treat to have someone
who never retires or decides it's time
to move to a different job
next up minimal I.T resources
maintaining software Bots requires
minimal it resources
in some cases it doesn't it doesn't need
to get involved at all
your RPA systems will be managed by the
software provider the response for
maintenance and updates all of that it
completely takes the burden off it and
saves your company a whole lot of money
Roi is visible now every organization
wants to quantify their gains many of
these organizations do not know how they
should determine their Roi
but when it comes to adopting robotic
process automation Roi is visible it
defines a clearer path to demonstrate
its risk returns
complex problems can be solved now as
our data sources and analytical
capabilities have grown so has the time
required to build various reports
robotic process automation system is
ideal to for solution to solve these
types of problems
the system stores the information and it
can also remember and transform this
information very easily
that means this makes you auditable and
tax ready
software migration
now it's a fact that software migrations
are time consuming and costly
migrating to a new software could take
months and cost could turn out to be
tens or thousands of millions of dollars
what's even more frustrating is that at
all times certain features and
functionalities which may have
functioned in a particular way in a
previous version may not even be present
in the updated version
so RPA helps with data migration with
accuracy speed and continuous updating
of software
RBA has a free tier
many RPA vendors offer free tiers some
of these vendors are blue prism
automation anywhere uipath among others
these RPS software vendors are offering
High RPA software notably uipath with
their Community Edition and work fusion
with their RPA Express
this helps lower the total cost of
ownership
there's no rip and replace
now RPA doesn't jeopardize an employee's
job but helps with the growth of new
jobs
to do your work you need some additional
software yes and virtual machines to
deploy fully independent digital Bots
but you may not need to rip and replace
your existing infrastructures
also there's a common misconception that
RPA could steal our jobs
well that's not true monitoring and
controlling these Bots are completely
the responsibilities of the developer
as a result RPA does not pull down your
existing systems but it leverages them
lastly popularity and high salary
according to Glassdoor the average
salary of an RPA developer in the US is
77 000 US Dollars and in India the
beginning salary for an RPA developer is
around 4.65 lakhs per annum
top tier companies like Dell IBM
Accenture capgemony cognizant among
others are readily hiring RPA Developers
now with that let's move on to the
growth projections of RPA
now looking at the graph here both RPS
software and services
increased by huge amounts during between
2016 and 2020.
according to McKinsey research knowledge
and work automation could have an
economic impact of five to seven
trillion dollars by the year 2025. it
will touch more than 230 million
knowledge workers which on which
constitute about nine percent of the
global Workforce
any company which is labor intensive
where people are performing high volume
High transaction functions will boost
their capabilities and save money and
time with RPA
now this is all you need to know about
why one should learn RPA
but if you're looking to become a
developer let's look at some of the job
roles and responsibilities
RPA developers are responsible for the
creation design development and
implementation of RPA systems
an RPA developer is expected
to provide Guidance with process design
develop test automation workflows
deploy RPA competence be it Bots robots
or development tools
support the implementation of RPS
Solutions
create process documentation and also
assure the quality of the Automation in
this video we will be looking at the
robotic process automation example let
us consider a discussion between John
and Jim John is very curious and wants
to know how and where RPA is used in
different fields jme being a developer
helps John in understanding the RPA
examples even if you are curious to know
the applications of RPA then you are at
the right place so let's get started
the first example is customer service
let's look at the problem statement
a customer representative must
understand and solve the customer
queries carry out the necessary actions
by switching between the various
softwares and applications and inform
the customer
this must wait while the representative
is busy dealing with data sometimes
asking for information that has already
been requested this tends to decrease
customer satisfaction and extends call
duration the solution requires
identifying frequently Asked customer
questions assessing customer
representative actions in response to
those questions and developing RPS
solutions to facilitate those questions
when several sets of information need to
be coordinated across systems the
customer service representative can
launch a bot the bot completes all
actions in seconds with the Press of a
button for frequently asked questions a
dashboard can be created a customer
service representative will fill out the
necessary information to receive the
queries and Bots will use the data in
multiple systems to complete the
transaction let's look at an example
consider a scenario where a company was
providing support to the client and the
company was supposed to handle a large
number of calls approximately 20 000
calls per month which required a
significant amount of time spent in the
support team because of the system's
complexity and executive's average time
was about 10 minutes the system was
inefficient and slow resulting in a poor
customer service
with the RPS solution the organization
gained a virtual team that can complete
the task in less than a minute resulting
in a drastic reduction in an execution
time
the RPA board performs the following
task loading a comprehensive customer
profile obtaining a detailed building
information
user preferences and other user
information are being updated resolving
common but simple customer issues let's
look at the second example Financial
Service
Financial Service involves compiling and
combining financial information from
various departments and storing the
records in a system
data is manually extracted from a bank
statements to reconcile documents and
Link them to its forms using detailed
spreadsheets
to complete the reports business rely on
Excel Legacy software and manual labor
which is tedious and time consuming
solution robots can generate invoices in
seconds prompting clients to pay more
quickly RPA in financial services tracks
and standardizes and validates payments
process orders and avoid Sellers and is
always on top of things such a
disciplined assistant makes the
customers experience less stressful
adding value to the service provider
RPA in finance eliminates the need for
Endless email correspondence and ensures
a smooth payment approval process
matches invoices to responsible parties
and sets deadline reminders
automated data entry speeds up the
process and relieves human employees of
huge tasks this enables precise and
structured invoice processing
consider a financial service company
that's having difficulty extracting data
from financial documents efficiently and
accurately in order to generate ratings
using RPA company implemented an
application that recognized and
processed data this enable the client to
quickly and cost effectively automate
the tasks perform the RPA boards and
Financial Service are investment
management
reconciliation of bank statements
organizing the finances
record of accounts receivables and paid
the third example is HR service
this operation includes numerous routine
steps such as interview scheduling
record keeping resume screening
candidate shortlisting induction
training and onboarding hearing and
firing plays a significant burden on HR
and other support functions such as it
security and Facilities Management
particularly for medium and large
businesses while it is expensive to
build a solution that encompasses all of
these functions and completes the
necessary task for new or departing
employees some employees can be sloppy
with recording absences vacation or in
general using the existing absence
management system
so the possible solution for this is RPA
can be used to collect and Screen
resumes and online application forms
conduct through background checks and
compare the information to all relevant
job requisitions this allows the best
candidates to be shortlisted RPA can be
used quickly to create offer letters for
new employees that are both personalized
and accurate and also validate records
by cross checking data such as absentee
reports Against Time logged in the
corporate Network and alerting when
information is missing or inconsistent
as int acquisition team of a company
automated aspects of onboarding process
for new employees
previously the onboarding paperwork was
completed manually by one person
consuming a significant amount of
employees time that could have been
spent on more valuable work
this type of work that no one wants to
do day after day the company understands
that an HR department wants to provide a
digital and straightforward experience
the task required a lot of copy and
paste activities with the implementation
of RPA the bot completed the onboarding
paperwork in less time allowing HRS to
spend more time on corporate social
responsibilities hiring Talent
initiatives and improving a company's
reputation
the tasks performed by RPA boards in HR
service are screening resumes onboarding
of new hires attendance management
induction and training employment
management and Survey report
the fourth example is telecom service
the Telecommunications industry involves
high frequency of manual repetitive
rules-based processes all of which are
critical for providing appropriate
Service delivery thus the foundation of
telecommunications is made up of process
that are highly amenable to automation
for telecommunication companies looking
to improve their customer service High
reliability and accuracy of process
outcomes are required
solution the use of robotic process
Automation in Telecom reduces error
rates to close to zero improves data
quality improves customer service and
increases operational efficiency all
while contributing significantly to cost
reduction
RPA technology can capture the business
process task performed by a telecom
company's employees based on the
employee section A well-structured
workflow can be generated which serves
as the foundation for automated process
by mapping each process step with its
significant cost for manual execution it
is simple to determine which action
should be automated to maximize return
on the investment
consider an example a telecommunications
and Media company decided to automate
its order creation and service removal
process to cut cost associated with the
company Speed Booster discount service
and deal with a massive amount of
transactional data
with the implementation of RPA it
becomes simple to automate the order
build process and service removal
activity
the task performed by RPA boards in
Telecom services are
it checks on the credit and SIM card so
happen the solution of customer
complaints reporting customer phone
numbers responding to questions from
partners
the fifth example is healthcare service
Healthcare Systems contain numerous
burdensome tasks that involve
significant resource allocation such as
claim management this results in high
operational cost and slow process
every industry has inefficiencies but
few face the healthcare industry's
challenges strict regulations regarding
patient data and lack of resources to
deal with such rules billing takes time
after a healthcare service is provided
due to manual and repetitive task in the
management process
management process include document and
data input processing and evaluation in
addition to the automating time
consuming task patients can schedule
appointments without the intervention of
hospital employees credit to RPA
technology
along with eliminating the need of
resource allocation for scheduling by
allowing patients to reschedule
appointments more quickly this
application can improve customer
relations RTA allows Healthcare
Providers to track and document each
process step in structured log files to
comply with external audits RPA improves
data confidentiality because Bots handle
this process
let's consider an example daily a
healthcare organization deals with the
process of patient transaction Data
customer detailed recording claims to
the process and data reconciliation for
healthcare schemes are some of the
manual process they must streamline
daily the primary goal was to increase
the efficiency of existing approaches to
achieve greater accuracy with reduced
turnaround time
robotic process automation was
implemented at the most significant
possible impact was obtained RPA
platform handled claims processing and
held data reconciliation program
Healthcare was able to reduce turnaround
time with this solution
the tasks performed by RPA boards in
healthcare services are appointment
scheduling Regulatory Compliance data
entry and supporting analytics to
improve treatment in this video we are
going to compare the most commonly used
RPA tools namely blue prism uipath and
automation anywhere
so what's in it for you
first we learn why exactly RPA came into
picture and then what exactly RPA is
lastly we'll compare the tools based on
trial version base Technologies process
designer accessibility macro recorders
architecture learning robots accuracy
reusability pricing and then
certification
so without further Ado let's begin and
understand why was RPA introduced
used consider the process of onboarding
a recruit your organization
the whole process will involve tasks
like creating a new user account a new
email address access rights documents
retrieval and so on so instead of doing
all of this manually one can automate
the process
so with RPA the user can automatically
activate a template for the onboarding
workflow RPA can help assess prepare and
create new join e data initiate mailing
of offer letters and streamline the
information across different systems
so what is RBA robotic process
automation is the use of software with
artificial intelligence and machine
learning capabilities to handle high
volume repeated tasks that previously
required humans to perform
now some of these tasks could include
addressing queries making calculations
maintaining records or even making
transactions
now rbe tools are the software through
which one can configure tasks that are
to be automated so some of the widely
used tools are uipath Studio automation
anywhere blue prism work Fusion among
others
now assuming you have a basic
understanding of RPA let's go on and
compare the popularly used tools
first up is trial version every tool
generally offers a trial version for its
users to get acquainted with the tool
this helps the users understand the tool
better and decide if they want to
proceed with using the tool
looprism offers a free trial version
it's available in two options either on
the cloud or on the local computer
uipath also offers a free edition
both trial and license versions are
available
automation anywhere offers a free
community version and both trial and
licensed versions are available
next up is base Technologies
base Technologies Define the technology
with which the software was built blue
prism is based on C sharp uipath is
based on Microsoft vendors like
SharePoint kibana and elasticsearch
while automation anywhere is based on
Modern Java Technologies
foreign
feature of comparison is process
designer
blue prism enables you to create design
edit as well as test business processes
from the visual business object
now ovbo is like an adapter provided by
Blue prism for communicating with an
application
each visual business object implements a
specific set of operations on an
application's user interface
so these are basically like objects that
encapsulate a particular functional
logic
UI path on the other hand acts as a
visual process designer with developer
friendly options
now a visual process designer is a
dashboard consisting of various tools
through which the developer can Define
the automation tasks
automation anywhere is developer
friendly with the visual interface built
for business users along with Advanced
features for developers business users
and developers can work side by side to
build Bots they can see the visual
interface and code in a single screen
the next feature of comparison is
accessibility blue prism offers
browser-based access only uipath and
automation anywhere on the contrary or
for both application based and
browser-based accessibility
in case of automation anywhere the
control room can be accessed with a
browser or a mobile application this is
the only platform where users can create
bots on any device or any operating
system
moving on to the next feature
learning
now in case of Blue prism the user
should have the necessary knowledge of
programming he should be able to create
business objects and manage them in the
control center
uipath enables you to design automation
processes visually through diagrams the
developer need not know a programming
language in particular
when it comes to automation anywhere it
is developer friendly and offers both
Visual and programming features business
users can build Bots with the help of
track and drop features beginners
benefit from the built-in product
walkthrough
next up is robots
now before we jump in let's discuss what
the different types of bots are there
are two types of ports you have the
front office Bots whose deployment is in
the user's control
you also have back office Bots and it
can run on locked machines from an
orchestrator the user may not be
actively involved in its working
so moving on to the comparison
blue prism offers back office automation
only uipath and automation anywhere
offer both front and back office
automation
in case of automation anywhere the HBC
or the human bot collaboration feature
enables humans and Bots to work together
to complete a task and also to manage
exceptions and escalations
moving on the next feature is macro
recorder
or the macro recorder allows you to
record keyboard activities and mouse
events to generate automation Scripts
these activities are arranged based on
the order or sequence of actions being
performed on the screen
so moving on to the comparison blue
prism does not use a macro recorder
uipath makes use of a macro recorder to
enable fast process mapping automation
anywhere offers a universal recorder so
that the user need not select different
recorders for different tasks
moving on to the next feature
architecture
an application that runs on the client
side and accesses the remote server for
information uses a client server
architecture whereas an application that
runs entirely on a web browser uses the
web architecture
in case of a client server architecture
the user interaction with the server is
always through a user interface or
application on the client side
on the other hand in a web application
the user interaction is Thoroughly
through a web browser
now blue prism and uipath both
incorporate a client server architecture
automation anywhere incorporates a cloud
native web-based microservices
architecture it is the only platform
that provides a complete digital worker
Solution on the web
users with any skill level can instantly
start building robots on a browser
without any heavy installation
the next feature is accuracy
blue prism is accurate for desktop web
and Citrix automation
uipath shines in Citrix automation
designed for BPO automation
and automation anywhere shines in
settings automation with AI Sense
Technology
well any automation solution built using
a virtual desktop or bill to work in
Virtual desktops is called Citrix
automation
moving on to the next feature
reusability
view prism consists of a library of
business objects that can be reused
across multiple methods it also offers
High reliability
in the case of uipath the processes can
be used for various synthesis services
with several workflow modules as a
result uipath offers a high degree of
usability and moderate reliability
in the case of automation anywhere apart
from the standard common Library users
can develop custom actions upload and
manage packages in their Enterprise
control room every bot created in
automation anywhere is reusable
the bot store has hundreds of
pre-configured bots and digital workers
to kick-start a user's RPA Journey
next up is pricing blue prism has a high
cost of acquisition it also offers
restricted training
uipath offers effective Pleasant
entry-level pricing
automation anywhere offers attractive
its users also experience the lowest
total cost of ownership because of its
native capabilities and web-based
architecture
moving on to the last feature
certifications
looprism offers several certifications
like blueprison professional developer
blue prism ROM architect among others
uipath provides free online training and
certification programs like RPA
developer Advanced certification
automation anywhere university offers
free online training and certification
programs for both students and advanced
practitioners
professionals can also Avail job role
specific certifications
there are several RPA tools in the
market today however blue prism
automation anywhere and uipath are
leading the market let's get started
with what is uipath
UI path is a robotic process automation
tool for large scale end-to-end
automation for an accelerated business
change it provides solution for business
to automate routine office activities
it uses a variety of methods to
transform tedious tasks into automated
process
Daniel dines and Maria stirka Romanian
entrepreneurs founded uipath in
Bucharest in 2005. the first uipa
desktop automation product line was
launched in 2013 giving business RPA
tools to automate manual and repetitive
back office task
let's look at the features of uipath
drag and drop workflow the user of
uipath will develop visual process steps
by dragging and dropping related tasks
onto the graphical workspace then with
the user interface properties they can
transform those process steps into a
visual workflow
users may also use the recorder wizard
in the uipath tool to build web-based or
application workflows
the next feature is record and Playback
the user can use this function to record
actions and transform them into
automated process series
UI path has the following types of
recording options
basic recording it focuses on automating
single task and is commonly used to
develop each activity's complete
selector
desktop recording it can be used for a
variety of actions as well as actions
development
web recording it is a common tool for
viewing and recording web page
activities so it takes recording it is
very widely used for recording stuff
like pictures and virtualized
environment automation
next we have inbuilt activities in
uipath uipath comes with over 300
built-in activities covering a wide
range of process Automation and
application integration design tasks
these activities are found in activities
pane which covers most design tasks such
as data extraction data entry and
automation
next we have advanced scraping options
scraping data from web pages and
applications is easier with UI path
screen scraping
furthermore the data screen scraping
wizard helps in scraping of data with a
repetitive structure scraping solution
Works flawlessly with any program
including dotnet Java flash PDF Legacy
and sap
next we have high security and
robustness we can create super smart
durable robots with uipath with a simple
visual canvas everyone in the company
can use Bots
uipath offers high security Auto login
functionality to run the Bots and
operates with a locked screen allowing
automated process to run in complete
privacy
let's look at the components of uipath
the first component we have uipath
Studio uipath robot and uipath
orchestrator
let's look at them one by one this is
how a uipath studio looks like uipath
studio is a user friendly interface
inside the tool that allows user to
visually plan and design various
automation process through diagrams
using drag and drop functionality
these diagrams are merely a structural
reflection of specific tasks that must
be completed
this is the activity pane in the uipath
studio it consists of project activities
and Snippets
this is the ribbon tab it consists of
saving options opening new files
debugging files recording screenscaping
data scripting and many more we will
explore this in the demo section
next we have output pane where output is
being displayed
and we have the properties pane where
the properties of each activity is shown
here
the next component is uipath robot after
you have built your process the next
move is to put into action in the uipath
studio
uipath robots are used to translate the
process into tasks which are then
executed these robots are used to assign
various tasks and carry them out in the
same manner as humans but without human
interference
when given operation occurs on the
computer UI path robots are programmed
to begin executing task automatic
next we have UI path orchestrator the
orchestrator is a web-based application
in uipath it has features like deploying
monitoring scheduling and controlling
automated Bots and process
it's a centralized forum for managing
and controlling all software Bots
let's look at the architecture of uipath
it consists of two sections the client
side and the server side and the three
layers let us look at them one by one we
will first look at decline side and the
server side
blank said UI path components are those
that the user or developer can
communicate with directly uipath Studio
uipath robot browser and uipath agent
are usually included uipath backend
operation are considered server side the
task and workflows that a user produces
are saved in the databases uipath
orchestrator chooses the necessary
function and the software robots to
carry out the code's task the robots
logs and statistics are stored in the
back end locks are useful for analyzing
robot performance and detecting errors
in them the two elements comprise the UI
path robot agent support for UI path and
the executor service for uipath the
agent support for uipath is the service
in uipath that serves as the mediator
between the client side and the server
side of uipath all of the information
and data are conveyed via the Handler
messages are also logged into the
orchestrator before being moved to the
SQL Server the service can be used to
search all of the currently available
tasks in the device tray it also can
change device settings and start and
stop the current task
execute a service for uipath in this the
software robots use this service to
carry out the tasks specified in the
windows session
now let us look at the three layers
first one is the presentation layer this
UI path components that are open to the
users make up the client layer uipath
Studio robots browsers uipath agent and
executors for example a user or a
developer may use this components to
design and create different tasks that
can be automated computer robots are
commonly used to complete this task the
client layer is an another name for the
presentation layer let us look at the
service layer the UI paths architectures
most significant sheet the cloud layer
shows all server information the uipath
orchestrator is the most significant
part of the server layer when the robots
can perform the task the entire project
is periodically uploaded to the server
within the aid of an orchestrator the
project is often carried out through
several structures the orchestrator is
in charge of the whole band it keeps
track of the project development
schedule software robots for execution
and produce a summary reports based on
the filtered parameter it assists in the
synchronization of software robots so
that they can continue to perform
routine task it helps our project meet
project requirements service levels and
deadlines thanks to its web-based
management system
now let us look at the persistence layer
database servers make up the bulk of
this sheet during this layer all of the
robot's configuration information is
saved users insert data robots assign
tasks logging information and assets
among the other items into the arcade
status configuration details furthermore
persistency layer is in charge of
keeping the log information updated by
the uipath agent Services
elasticsearch is used to store this
locks the locks are primarily useful for
locating and correcting errors
process level data is usually saved in
relational database Management systems
such as SQL Server this makes processing
logs from the vast volume of data a lot
simpler hence the queues tasks are often
taken care by the persistency layer
let's look at some of the applications
of uipath
in sales in sales UI path is used to
generate invoice this is an example of
data replication in action both CRM and
accounting systems must have the same
sales details Bots can update accounting
records prepare and send invoices from
the appropriate email addresses instead
of manually replicating data
it is also used in keeping scorecards up
to date companies that do not have HR
and CRM systems integrated can use RPA
boards to ensure that CRM adjustments
are submitted to scorecards in real time
allowing sales reps to track their
progress
it is used in CRM updating a new class
of solution is evolving to incorporate
their email call and other contact data
into CRM a simple bot could be written
to update your CRM records with customer
contact information if you can't find a
suitable solution for using the CRM
systems
next it is used in banking in banking it
is used to check kyc
though dedicated kyc Solutions are
evolving RPA Bots can be used to
automate portions of the kyc process if
your organization does not want to use
one
a case may be referred to an employee in
the event of an edge case that requires
human involvement
it is used in sanction of loans like
most document process activities this
method is appropriate to RP automation
because complex business logic can be
embedded in Bots which can partially
automate loan decisions and the manual
process that follow
it is used in execution of trade RPA
Bots may be useful in situations where
Legacy systems are incapable of storing
complex limit orders however this is
more a Band-Aid solution in the long run
switching to a sophisticated and
competent trading system will certainly
be a smart investment considering how it
could increase trading and minimize
Trader workload
next it is used in healthcare in
healthcare it is used for appointment
scheduling
the RPA bot makes appointment for
patient based on their diagnosis Dr
availability location and other factors
such as financial statement and
insurance details
it is used in supporting analytics to
improve patient treatment RPA Bots May
collect a variety of medical information
RPA boards for example can use patient
data to a third party Healthcare
analytics provider to provide more
reliable diagnosis and better patient
care without violating any
confidentiality regulations
let's look at the benefits of uipath
increase productivity uipath automates
with quick speed and accessibility
consider an RPA bot that allows a worker
to produce a monthly report in 20
minutes instead of manually taking 4
hours the Communist productivity could
increase as a result of process
automation
next we have high efficiency RPS
software does not need a break it can
operate 24 hours a day a single RPA
robot may replace two to five full-time
workers if not more robots can do the
same amount of work in less time or more
work at the same time than humans
customer experience in RPA adopted
business routine and repetitive and
boring tasks are assigned to robots
allowing employees to focus more on
Customer Service Company may make
consumer needs with the help of
professional and knowledgeable employees
highly secure there is no risk of
information leakage from one component
to another because it performs single
tasks as a result data access is
strictly monitored and reported
cost effective uipath has minimal
operating cost and more efficient use of
it resources let's look at the top
companies hiring UI part Developers
Infosys IBM Deloitte ey KPMG
let's look at the salary trends for
uipart Developers
the average pay scale for a UI part
developer in India is 5 lakh 45 000
rupees
uipa developer salary ranges from 362
000 Rupees to 1 million in USA the UI
power developer salary ranges from 58
000 to 107 000 and the average salary is
seventy six thousand dollars
let's look at a demo consider a scenario
where you have multiple Excel files you
want to combine the data in single file
in this demo we will merge two Excel
files into a single Excel file and send
it over an email let's create automation
to merge two Excel files using uipath
from here we can open a new project or
existing project stored locally or on
Version Control System
with the click we can open a new project
or create a new project from a template
uipath offers many templates depending
on what you are trying to do for now
let's start with a blank project
so we'll open a blank project here
so we'll open a main workflow
then we'll go to new and select a new
sequence
we can do it using a flowchart as well
but for now I'll show you doing a
sequence
so we'll open the sequence and we'll
name the sequence
since we are merging two files I'll name
it as
merging files
and I'll click
so we'll go to the activities pane
firstly we need to drag and drop a read
CSV activity
so search for read CSV
so drag and drop read CSV activity
since we are using two Excel files so we
need to read CSV activities
and read from the file we need to select
the file location
so
we'll select the file location sample
CSV file one
and add the file to
select another file location
sample CSV file
at the output side
will create a variable
and name it as SL underscore file 1.
foreign
CSV
we'll create a variable and name it as a
cylinder score
file to
so this much is done now we need an
assign activity
so we'll search for assign activity
so we'll drag and drop
assign activity has two parameters two
and enter an expression
so in the two we'll create a variable
name name it as
merged
Excel
and and in the expression
write an expression
say SL underscore
file one
dot clone
why are you using a clone function the
Clone function creates a new data table
with same structure but does not copy
the data oops it's showing an error here
so what's the error
so we need to
assign the variable type
to be
system.data.data table
here we go
error has got
so after using the assign activity we
need to merge the data table so we need
merge data table activity
so search for merge
data table here we go and drag and drop
it
we need too much data table activities
so tag and drop
and specify the destination and Source
here
destination is the merged Excel
and the source is the
SL underscore file one for the First
Data Mass table
similarly for second merge data table
destination remains same
foreign
so this is done
so next we need to drag and drop a write
CSV file
write CSV file creates an output file in
which you want to merge the two files
so search for
like CSV
here we go drag and drop it
so choose the path create the file so
you can see there is no output file here
so we'll create the output file now
which is an empty file
so output dot CSV
so we have created an output file
so right from we'll write it as merged
Excel
you need a data from merge list
[Music]
so the output file is created so now we
need to send the file over and mail so
for that we need to drag and drop a get
password activity
so we'll search for get password
activity
here we go drag and drop it
and
once you get this get password activity
enter the password Here enter your
password email ID password
so there is a prerequisite when you use
get password
to receive a mail go to your Google
account Google account go to your
security option and in security there is
an option called less secure app access
turn that on
I'll repeat turn on the list secure app
access okay once the get password is
done
go to the result section
in the results section right click and
create a variable
name it something maybe SSS
so I
created a variable there
so we need a last activity now
that is smt mail message
SMTP
mail message
that I can drop it
so in the host port and enter this
server
so the server you have to enter it as
SMTP
dot Gmail
call should be in the double quotes
SMTP dot Gmail
.com
and enter the port number as
587.
and enter your email ID here
which is
your own email ID I'll enter my
once you enter the email ID enter the
password
what we had created
so that's done so enter the email ID
here
enter the subject whatever you want
so I will enter it as much
data
most Excel files
enter the body
so we'll attach the file
so what is the file which we are
attaching here
so we are attaching the output file what
we have named it as output dot CSV file
so that's it we'll run the program
and run the code
sample execution has started
and within the 10 seconds sample
execution has ended
so we'll go and check if we have
received the mail
so this is my email ID
here we go we have received the email
here
let's open this let's open the output
file
here we go we can see the data is being
merged
and if you go to the file where the
documents were stored here you go this
way the two files the sample file 1 and
Sample File 2 and this is the merged
file which was created let me show you
the sample file 1.
and Sample file 2.
so this is the sample file 1 with 10
rows
and this is sample File 2 which also has
10 rows
so this is File 2 with 10 rows and file
1 with 10 rows
and here we go this is the
output file
which has both tent and rows merged here
we go
it is sent over and make in this video
we will be looking at the installation
of uipath so let us see the requirements
we will first look at the hardware
requirements the CPU should at least
have a processor of 1.4 gigahertz 32-bit
configuration or it's recommended to
have a 1.8 gigahertz 64-bit
configuration
the device is recommended to have a ram
of 8 GB if not at least a minimum of 4
GB
let us look at the software requirements
if you are using a Windows operating
system then Windows should be of version
8.1 or 8.1 n or 10 or 10 n and the
Windows Server should be of 2012 R2 2016
or 2019 versions another prerequisite is
to have.net framework of minimum of
4.5.2 version installed
let us look at the additions
the different editions that uipath
offers uipath offers two types of
additions Community Edition and
Enterprise Edition Community Edition is
for the developers and small teams who
are just starting on their automation
Journey the Enterprise Edition is
further classified into three types
Enterprise Studio Edition Enterprise
Cloud Edition and Enterprise server
Edition
so Enterprise Studio Edition is for
individual Enterprise developers who
want to experiment with uipath Studio
price cloud is a cloud-based deployment
of entire RPA Enterprise platform for
any size business Enterprise server
on-premises deployment for entire
Enterprise automation platform for large
scale business
let us look at the different profiles in
uipath UI path Studio X uipath studio
and uipath Studio Pro uipath Studio ax
is for business users if you are not a
developer but if you want to automate a
simple task then it is easy to use a
studio X
uipath Studio that is for RPL developers
build complex automation that is run by
attended or attended robots uipath
Studio Pro it is for the specialized
developers automatic with AI Advanced
RPA features testing tools and
sophisticated coding services
so we will look at the installation
let us install uipath
go to any one of the browser and search
for uipath.com
this will take you to the official
uipath website
here you can see try uipath for free
click here
since I have already registered before
it is showing as continue to existing
organization if you are visiting this
website for the first time then you
might have to register or sign in using
an email account
after signing in and filling all the
details you can continue
here you can see download UI path Studio
click on this and download the UI path
Studio
here you go the uipath studio setup file
is getting downloaded
once the UI path file is downloaded run
the setup file and here you can see the
UI path is getting installed after
installation it will ask for a license
Select Community license which is free
after selecting the license you need to
choose a profile here are three profiles
uipath Studio Pro which is the advanced
Studio IDE it has features like testing
tools Advanced RPA features and coding
services
another profile is uipath Studio
it is for developers who have clear
programming experience
and the last profile is the uipath
studio X it is for the people who don't
have any programming experience
so we will select uipath Studio X for
now next UI path will ask you to update
the channel you can either select the
stable version or preview version
we will select the stable version for
now after you select the versions you
need to select the source control
plugins you can enable Git Version
Control System or Apache sub version and
Azure devops server to uipath provides a
short introduction video tutorials to
learn how to build automations following
step-by-step instructions and an academy
to take free training on the uipath
academy
so that's it you have successfully
installed uipath Studio
from here you can open a new project new
template and start building the first
Automation in this video
we will learn about uipath studio in
depth and understand it's working with
the demo
so what is uipath
now RPA is a technology with which human
tasks can be automated
to facilitate this a tool is required
uipath is one such tool among others
that are used to create Bots with the
help of visual processes and diagrams
it provides complete end-to-end
automation calling it hyper automation
uipath was founded by Daniel dines and
Mario sturka in 2005.
uipath is specially used for Windows
process automation
it automates repetitive tasks
and lastly uipath offers drag and drop
functionalities to make it easy to use
now since there are so many other tools
like blue prism automation anywhere in
the market what makes uipath stand out
so let's look at the advantages of
uipath
first uipath has an activity Library
this library has several built-in
activities and features like display
message
input box and so on
this improves the customer experience
we will deal with these activities in
The Demolator
next up is security
RPA deals with a variety of information
like credit card numbers financial
information and passwords
uipath offers extensive security since
all the information can be encrypted and
stored on a centralized server
up next we have recorders
so uipath uses a micro recorder to
record the user actions such as Mouse
clicks and keystrokes once the actions
are recorded they can be emulated using
emulators for quick automation
third party integration
uipath can be integrated with
third-party plugins like IBM Watson and
Google plugins
then we have powerful debugging
uipath Studio comes with a debug
component that helps find and locate
problems easily in complex workflows
this is useful for viewing the execution
of each activity to verify what data it
gets and if there are addressing
producing outputs
now let's understand the various uipath
products
first up is uipath Studio
this is the platform to create the Bots
this product consists of all the
necessary drag and drop activities and a
robust UI to help develop bots of your
choice now the uipath studio consists of
the GUI dashboard it offers a visual
dashboard with activities like send
email display message and so on
then we have types of recorders uipath
Studio offers various types of recorders
to record actions on multiple platforms
then we have logging and exception
handling
it offers various options for debugging
and exception handling such as debug
open logs slow step Etc and finally we
have reusable components the user can
create reusable components to publish
them together as libraries
next we have the uipath robots
all the automation tasks that created
are run by uipath robots
there are two types of robots
attended robots and unattended robots
attended robots work with you to speed
up service desk and help desk it is used
in activities where human involvement is
the key
unattended robots operate without human
touch maximizing cost and performance
benefits for any variety of back office
tasks
lastly we have the uipath orchestrator
the orchestrator is like a centralized
entity where you can deploy secure
manage all your automation tasks
here are the steps involved first
you create a bot now you create a
project and publish it as a process for
further use
once a process is created it is assigned
to a specific robot to execute in an
environment
this collectively constitutes a job
now let's move on to the architecture of
uipath
so on the top
you have the client layer consisting of
uipath studio and the uipath robot
now the uipath robot has two parts
one is the uipath agent service which
displays all the available jobs in the
system tray and the other one is the
uipath executor service which is used to
run the jobs in one Windows session
the server layer receives the robot once
it is ready for execution with the help
of the orchestrator you can run the
project on different PCS
the orchestrator monitors the deploys
configures queue management and logging
lastly we have the persistent layer
which consists of the databases it takes
care of the queues and holds information
about the robot configuration and the
assigned processes
now that we know what uipath is let's
acquaint ourselves with its user
interface and understand its components
better
so this is what the typical interface
looks like
first we have the ribbon
it consists of three tabs home design
and debug
whom is where you start a new project
from predefined templates or open a
project you recently worked on by
default the projects are created in the
location shown below
next is the design tab
design tab adds sequences flowcharts and
state machines to your project it
installs and manages activity packages
it builds interactions with UI elements
and then publishes your work to
orchestrator
finally is debug
it debugs your workflow by using
debugging tools to set up breakpoints
monitor the execution of activity step
by step and adjust the debugging speed
next on the screen is tools
so the tools tab can be used for
installing extensions from chrome
Firefox Edge Java Silverlight Citrix and
windows remote desktop and is also used
for launching the UI Explorer and
project dependencies Mass update tool
then we have settings
the settings tab has options for
changing the interface language theme
setting Global preferences and managing
activity feeds
so you have general settings then there
is settings for design locations manage
resources and finally license and
profile
up next you have help
the help tab directs you to product
documentation release notes online
resources the community forum and the
RPA Academy
after that you have the recorder
the recorder component in uipath studio
allows the user to record UI Mouse
movements and keyboard activities to
generate automation Scripts
after that you have scraping
so uipath Studio supports two types of
scraping one is screen scraping and the
next one is data scraping so screen
scraping is programmatic collection of
visual data and data scripting is the
extraction of structured data from an
application
then you have user events
user events records events such as Mouse
clicks and keystrokes
then you have variables so variables
hold different types of data these
variables can change over time uipath
makes an easy provision to create and
remove unused variables
on the bottom left you have project so
the project panel enables you to view
the components of the current project
add folders open the file location
manage dependencies and adjust project
settings
beside it you have activities panel so
the activities panel shows available
activities that can be added to the
current workflow users can use the
search box to find activities navigate
through them using navigation keys and
press
you also have the Snippets panel which
enables you to easily reuse automation
it includes by default multiple samples
and Snippets
to the bottom right you have the
properties panel which is contextual and
enables you to view and change the
properties of a selected activity
you also have the outline panel which
displays the project hierarchy all
available variables and nodes
you can highlight activities in this
panel by selecting them in the designer
panel
the output panel enables you to display
the output of the log message or write
line activities among other things
exceptions for packages are also
displayed in this panel
so now that you have understood the
interface of uipath let's look at the
companies using uipath
so you have Accenture capgemini
cognizant atos and Deloitte to name a
few
now we'll do a demo to automate a task
using uipath Studio
so here is what we are going to do in
the demo
we'll create an automated process to
fetch data from a website wherein the
bot would extract data like the name of
the person the phone number and the
email ID
this data will store it in an Excel
sheet and send it over an email
now let's get started
now to do this demo we'll be using the
fake name generator website to Generate
random data of people and store this
data set in an Excel sheet
now if I had to do this manually I would
first create an Excel sheet so let me
open an Excel workbook
I'll create a blank workbook
so this is where I'll put my data if I
had to do it manually
so now let me take you to
the fake name generator website so I'll
search for
fake name generator.com
so this is the website where you can
generate
fake names
now if I had to store this data in Excel
I would manually copy paste each and
every detail and paste it onto the Excel
sheet
so for that
first I had to create columns like name
then
phone number
this in
then email
after that
I had to come back to this
and
copy each of these fields
the name
fat take the phone number
so I would copy this
and similarly for the email address as
well
for one record it is fine
what if you were asked to fetch 100
records or say 200 records then this
method is not at all feasible
it is time consuming and inefficient
you need to find a way where you can
automate this task of fetching records
uipath is a solution for this
so let's see how we can automate this
task using the uipath studio
so I'll click on open main workflow
first we need to direct uipath to go to
the fake name generator website
for that we need the sequence activity
so let me search for sequence here
so under activities
I'll search for
sequence
and
I'll drag it
here
after that
I need to open the website in a web
browser
so for that let me search for another
activity called open browser so under
activity
I look for open browser
so I'll drag it on the sequence itself
now
it is asking you to insert the URL of
the website
and it must be within double quotes
so I'll go to my website
copy paste the URL
I have to give this URL within double
quotes then I'll paste it
now we need to select the name of the
browser where you want to open this
website
so under input and browser type
I'll choose Chrome
now let me go ahead and run this file
so
under debug I have run file
I'll click on it
so as you can see the website is
automatically opened in a new window on
Chrome
I'll close this
the next step in the process is to tell
the program how many records we want to
fetch from the website
for this we will create an input dialog
box
so
under activities
I'll search for input
so here you get the input dialog box
I'll drag and drop it on the top
now
it is asking us to give the details so
I'll
put it within double quotes say enter
the
details of customers
or say
people
and then here
I'll give enter the number of
records you want to fetch
now
now I have to store this information in
a variable
so under variables
I'll create a variable and name it as
total
is the total number of Records I want to
fetch
similarly under output result I'll keep
the same variable name as total
now we need to fetch the details a
number of times repeatedly say for 10
times or 20 times or 50 times
to do this operation
I'll be using a do while loop
so to use a do while loop
I'll first search for
do while
and I'll drop it to the do section of
the sequence
as you can see
do while has two components one is the
body
and the other one is condition
the body has the things that you want
the program to do
the condition is where you evaluate
certain conditions every time when the
program has to do a task
so for every step or iteration
it will check if the condition is true
or not and go inside the body of the
loop
now for doing this we need to assign a
variable
so
let's name the variable as
Val
and I'll change the variable type to
integer
and I'll make the scope to sequence
I'll also assign a default value of 0
now we'll compare this Val to the
variable total
so the condition I'll give is check if
Val is less than total
so under condition
I'll give Val less than
total
so every time the value of Val is less
than the total
it will keep fetching the records from
the website
you can see it has thrown some error
now this is because
our total variable is of type string
while the Val variable is of type
integer
so you can't compare an integer
with a string variable
so that would be absurd
we need to convert the total variable to
an integer using the C int function
so here itself I'll write C int which is
convert this total variable to integer
you can see the error is gone
the next thing I want to do is if the
value of the valve variable is less than
total I'll increment the value of Val to
1.
so to do that
I'll use an activity called assign
so I'll check for assign
and I'll drag it onto the body
so here I'll give
Val
equals to Val
Plus 1.
this will make sure the value of Val
increases by 1. every time there is a
new record inserted
it will continue until the value of Val
no longer matches the total
so the next job is to extract
information from the website
to do this we will use the get full text
activity
so I'll search for get full text here
and I'll drag it right below the assign
activity
now
you need to select the information which
you want
so first I want to get the name
I'll click on the indicate element
inside browser
and then select the name of the person
so I'll click on this
and
I click on the name
there you go
now
we need to store this name in a variable
so I'll create a variable
so under variable I'll create
a variable called name
and
in the output also
I'll give the same variable name
next I want to fetch the phone number of
the person
so I'll again select get full text
and I'll drag it
here
I'll click on indicate element inside
browser
so I'll scroll down
and I'll select the phone number of the
person
so we have selected the phone number
similarly I'll store this phone number
in a variable
I'll create a variable called
phone underscore number
and
the output text box also will
give the same variable as
phone underscore number
after that I want to get the email
address of the person
so I'll continue with the same drill
I'll select the activity once again
which is get full text and I'll drag it
right here
I'll click on indicate element inside
browser
and now
we'll select the email address which is
this one
similarly
I'll store the email address in a
variable called email underscore ID
and in the output also will give the
same variable name which is email
underscore ID
now we need to store the names phone
numbers and email IDs into an Excel
sheet for that we need to create a data
table
so I'll search for data table under
activities
let me go ahead and do that
so I'll
foreign
data table and drag it right below the
input dialog box
now this table has to be assigned to a
variable
so let me do that
let me give a variable name as
fetch
underscore data underscore table
similarly
the output also will give the same
variable name which is
table
one thing I need to tell you here is we
change the variable type
so I'll select browse for types
and
look for data table
which is
system.data
I'll drill down
and search for data table which is this
one
click ok
we need to assign the column names to
this data table
so let me now do that
I'll
uncheck all this and select the columns
so you will give the First Column name
as
name itself
click on OK
select one more column
give it as
phone number
click ok
and then
we need the email address
I'll hit OK
so we are done
so first the data table is created and
then we'll write this data to an Excel
file
after that
we need to create rows for the data
table
for that I will search for row
under activities I'll search for row
and
I'll select
add row
I'll select add data row
I'll place it right below where we have
created all the variables
now I want to add a row for the name
phone number and email address
so under
input I'll select
array row
I'll expand this
and within curly braces
I'll give my variable names
so those would be name
give a comma and then
phone underscore number
comma
email
underscore ID
click ok
I made a mistake it should be within
curly braces
okay
now to tell the table to which it should
write the rows to we need to assign
under the data table name
so under data table
I'll give
fetch underscore data underscore table
for every iteration a record will be
added to the table
then we need to rephrase the page to
extract the next set of information
so for that
I will add another activity called click
and drop it right below the add data row
so under activities
I'll search for click
and I'll select
Mouse click
and I'll drop it right
below this one
now we need to indicate where do we want
to click from the browser
so
click on this
go on top
and
select generate
so we want to click on generate
next I will write the data to a CSV file
so I'll search for write CSV under
activities
and
I'll drop it towards the
end of the sequence
right here
now you need to give the location where
you want to place this file on your
system
and give the source from where it will
take the information
so let's give the location where you
want to place this file
I'll place it on my desktop itself
I'll name this as fetch
save it
and
for the source
I'll give
fetch underscore data underscore table
we are all set now let's run it
so under debug file I'll select
run file
I'll
enter the number of Records so let me
fetch 10 records click on OK
now this might take some time
I believe it has run successfully now
let me check for my CSV file that should
ideally be on my desktop
there you go so we have the CSV file let
me open it
you can see it has extracted
10 rows of data
and three columns namely name of the
person the phone number and the email
address
so we are done with the first task of
automatically generating data from a
website
the next task is to send this file over
email
now to send an email
you need the SMTP activity
so under
activities I'll search for SMTP
I'll drag it right below here
now we need to configure this
I'll be actually sending this email from
someone else's email ID to my email ID
so under 2
I'll give my email address which is
within quotes I'll type Abhijit Dot
biswalet
simply learn
.net
I'll give a subject
as
automatic
data extraction
under body I'll give something like I
please find a test
now we have to attach the file
we have to give the location of the file
here
so
let me go to properties
and
I'll select this
cancel
paste this here
followed by
the file name which is fetch
dot CSV
I'll click on OK
after that
I have to give the host port number
which is 465
and
the
and the server name
which is SMTP Dot
gmail.com
under log on
I'll give the sender's email ID
I have to give the password as well
under the receiver it's my email ID
which is simplylearn.net
for the sender I'll give the email ID as
Chinmay dot this Pandy at
simplylearn.net
foreign
name
so we are almost done let me now go to
debug file and run this
it is asking to enter the number of
records and give five click on OK
this will take some time so let's just
wait
so we have successfully run our program
now let me check my inbox if I have got
any mail from chin Mai
so there you go
I've got this email and Below you can
see
the fetch.csv file attached and it has
five rows
what is uipath orchestrator
uipath orchestrator is a web application
that allows you to orchestrate the
execution of repetitive business process
by uipath robots
orchestrator manages declaration
monitoring scheduling and controlling of
automated Bots and process
it serves as a point of integration for
third-party Solutions and applications
it's a centralized forum for managing
and controlling all software Bots
it can manage the entire robot Fleet
let's look at the orchestrated
capabilities
provision
provisioning establishes and maintains
the connection between the robots and
the web application
deployment deployment ensures that the
correct package versions are delivered
to the assigned robots for execution
configuration configuration looks after
the maintenance and delivery of the
robot environments and process
configuration
cues cues ensures that the workload is
distributed automatically across robots
monitoring monitoring managers user
permissions and keeps track of robot
recognition details
logging logging locks are stored and
indexed in a SQL database
interconnectivity interconnectivity
functions as a centralized contact point
for third-party Solutions or
applications
let's look at the orchestrated use cases
the strength of uipath orchestrator
comes from its ability to control the
entire robot sleep
let's look at the different use cases
the first is attended
this type of robot is activated by user
events and operates at the same
workstation as a humor orchestrator is
used with attended robots to provide a
centralized process deployment and
logging medium
unattended in Virtual environments
robots can run unattended and automate a
variety of process
the orchestrator is in charge of remote
execution control scheduling and support
for work queues in addition to the
attended robot capabilities
Studio or Studio X they have unattended
robot capabilities but it should only be
used to connect your studio or Studio x
to the orchestrator for creation
purposes
non-production robots are similar to
unattended robots but they can only be
used for research and development
attended unattended non-production
studio and Studio X robots can all be
operated from a single location let's
look at the orchestrator user interface
dashboard enables us to see charts and
statistics illustrating usage
information for all the orchestrator
components like process assets queues
schedules robots jobs and transactions
let's look at the tenant context to view
and control the tenant level entities in
your orchestrator pick tenant from the
sidebar menu
with only one instance of the
orchestrator multi-tenancy allows you to
isolate data these features help you to
automate various departments within your
organization while also ensuring that
orchestrator data is approved according
to your preferences
please bear in mind that all of the
information is contained in the same
database
let's look at the components one by one
robots
a robot is an execution host that runs
uipath Studio process you can add robots
edit them display the status and license
State adjust the environment they are
assigned to and change the runtime
settings on the robots tab you can also
see the logs that a single robot has
created
process can be downloaded and executed
automatically by robots using custom
settings
while building or editing a robot you
can configure automatic process
downloading logging level font smoothing
and resolution in the settings tab
folders
folders give you a fine grain control
over Automation and their Associated
organizations as well as staff through
the entire organization in the
orchestrator there are two types of
folders classic and modern classic
folders functionality is allowed by
default while modern folders
functionality must be enabled by the
host or the tenant administrator
users
a user is an individual with access
dependent capabilities whose View and
control of the orchestrator are
determined by the access rights granted
users can be developed and managed
either locally in the orchestrator or an
external directory
roles in orchestrator the roles tab help
you to handle user permissions The
orchestrator View that a consumer has is
defined by the role they have been
assigned a function allows you to
control view edit create and delete
permissions on all orchestrator pages
and modules
machines a machine page allows you to
provision and control machines in
preparation for registering robots with
the orchestrator
at least all of the machines that are
currently in operation as well as their
forms
it allows you to create a computer
whether it's standard or a template
packages
all projects published from uipath
studio and those manually imported are
displayed on the packages tab you can
display all available versions of any
package on the packages tab as well as
the status claims and release notes if
they are available
ml skills
ml skills retrieves and requests machine
learning skills from the AI fabric
service it authenticates the robot that
is running the machine learning skills
audit
the audit page shows the audit Trail for
all acts taken by orchestrator entities
several criteria including component
user action and time can be used to
filter the data on the audit page
credential stores
a credential store is named location
inside a safe store such as cyber Arc
where you can get robot credentials and
credential assets when you need them at
the tenant stage orchestrator encourages
the uses of several credential stores
web hooks webhooks make it easier to
integrate your uipath automation with
the rest of your app ecosystem
you can subscribe to the orchestrator
events and have them sent to the
external DCM BPM or CRM solutions to
notify various users about the new Q
items that can be processed cost
failures or process updates
license robot licensing is available
both at the host and the Tenant level in
the orchestrator on the license list
this enables you to shorten your
deployment time and handle activation
from a single location
within a single click you can trigger
renew delete and delegate licenses
alerts notifications for robots queue
objects triggers tasks procedures and
activities are shown on the alerts tab
you will receive updates from all of
your folders on this tab and you will
not be able to choose more granular
options alerts are sent in real time and
can be categorized as info success 1
error or fatal
settings
you can adjust various settings on the
setting tab including the time zone
email warning information account
information package feeds and
interactive authentication now let us
look with respect to the folder context
from the sidebar menu pick any available
folder to view and control the entities
within that folder
automations contains the following tabs
process jobs triggers analogs
the process page allows you to build new
process from uploaded packages manage
existing process and keep all of your
process up to date with the latest
package versions
this allows you to spread packages
through the entire organization users
and robots and execute process more
quickly from the job Stars
jobs on an uipath robot a job represents
the execution of a procedure the
execution of a job can be started in
either attended or unattended mode on
attended robots you can't run a job from
the orchestrator and they can't run
under a locked computer
triggers
triggers allow you to run jobs in a
predefined sequence at predetermined
intervals and if a new products are
added to your queues
logs the logs page shows you all of the
robot logs in all of the folders you
have access to
to access the locks tab you must have
view permission on the locks locks are
kept in the local database if the
orchestrator is in accessible monitoring
monitoring contains the following tabs
machines process queues and SLA
machines displays information about all
the existing runtimes on an aggregate
basis and allows you to check the
overall health of each runtime
process the process page allows you to
build new process from the uploaded
packages
managing existing process and keep all
of your process up to date
queues a queue is a storage container
that can accommodate an infinite number
of objects multiple types of data such
as invoice information or customer
information may be stored in queue
objects other systems such as sap or
Salesforce can be used to process this
data by default the data stored Inland
output from the queue items is in free
form SLA
displays SLA and risk SLA information
for all cues in the current folder with
SLA predictions allowed
this allows you to determine if the
newly added Q items will be processed on
time and if so what resources you will
need to devote to ensure that their SLA
is not violated
when the SLA is in danger of not been
reached you will be adequately informed
so that you can make the required
changes
use
contains the following tabs use and
review request
in the queues pages click on the review
request tab to show revision request the
page shows items in different queues
that have been allocated for revision
assets
assets are usually shared variables or
credentials that can be used through
several automation projects they allow
you to store unique information that the
robots can easily access
storage buckets
RPA developers may use storage buckets
to provide a per folder storage solution
when building automation projects
the storage buckets page shows you your
current bucket configuration and allows
you to build as many new storage buckets
as you need
testing
testing contains the following tabs test
sets
test cases test execution test schedules
and test data queues
let's say a test set is a collection of
any number of individual test cases each
intended to serve a specific function
the test sets page list of view
currently available test sets and allows
you to build new tests updating existing
once and run them
test cases the test cases page shows all
of your test cases from all of your
projects and app versions in one place
these are the test cases that are used
in and to make up your test sets
test executions your previously executed
test sets and their information are
shown on the test execution tab since
test sets are often subject to change
test executions act as an immutable
record of Any Given test sets execution
at a given point in time
test schedules allow you to run test a
predetermined intervals and in a
scheduled manner
test data queues using test data queues
you can store and manage your test data
the test data queue serves as a
container for Q items that are ready to
be consumed via various activities the
test data queue items are uploaded are
deleted based on the first in first out
concept
action catalogs
task catalogs are task containers that
allow you to categorize your task using
a variety of criteria
the catalog where a task is stored is
defined when the task is created using
Studio's build type task operation
in orchestrator the catalog must be
specified first if you mention a catalog
that has not been generated in an
orchestrator the task is created in
orchestrator without a catalog
settings
setting contains two tabs permissions
and machine permission a user is an
individual with access dependent
capabilities
whose View and control of the
orchestrator are determined by the roles
assigned to them
users may be installed locally in the
orchestrator or an external director
machines
you can use the machines page to
provision and manage system entities
which you can then use to bind uipath
robots to the orchestrator it lists all
of the machines that are currently in
use as well as their types machines are
Global tools which means they can be
accessed from any folder let's look at
the demo in this demo we will see how to
connect uipath robot with the
orchestrator
how to run workflow using the
let's go to the browser in the browser
enter platform.uipar.com
this will take you to the uipath.com
website
if you have already an account sign in
enter the password
click on sign
meanwhile open the UI path assistant
so this is the uipath assistant so
uipath robot is a kind of Representative
which runs the workflow
so we create a workflow in the uipath
studio then we upload it on the
cloud.stater then we configure different
robots to run this workflow now that we
have logged in to the orchestrator
go to the admin
so you need to click here to add tenant
for the uipath community free edition
you can add only one tenant so I have
already created an internet so this
option is disabled for me so when you
click on the add tenant for the first
type the tenant window will be displayed
then fill the tenant name password and
confirm the password and it will ask you
for name surname and email address which
is optional so after filling the details
click on provision the tenant and the
Tenant admin are created and displayed
in the tenants page
so as you can see the tenant is created
there is an option here users and groups
you can go to the users and you can see
the different users
so this is my user this is me now you
can go to the groups and see the
different groups are located and their
licenses
so now that we have created a tenant
I have named it an interest admit
let's open it
meanwhile you can open UI path assistant
open uipath assistant
this is the UI path robot there are two
different ways to connect robot to the
orchestrator one is signing in the UI
path assistant it will take the token
from the UI path orchestrator by user
authentication and it will directly
connect machine and your robot and the
other way is to manually connect
so we'll sign in
enter the password
now you can see here robot is connected
to the orchestrator
so when you sign in the robot will get
connected to the orchestrator you can go
here in the preferences
go to the orchestrator settings and you
can see connected and license
so let's go to the orchestrator
in the orchestrator go to the tenant
context
and here you can see the robot is
connected it's enabled
if you go to the machines
you can see the machine is also
connected
so you can see here
there is an unattended robot here
so to get this unattended robot what you
have to do is go to the users
select the user which you are using this
is my username
go to edit
and here
you should enable this unattended robot
enable this option and enter the
username to get the username you can
open the command prompt and enter who am
I so you will get the username copy
paste the username enter the password
and click on update
and the unattended robot will retreat
so that is how you create the unattended
robot
now that we have connected robot to the
orchestrator let's open the uipath
studio we'll create a workflow and then
we'll run it using the robot
so now we have opened the uipath studio
let's open a blank process
after opening the uipath studio
click on open main workflow
first we'll drag and drop a sequence
then we need a input dialog box we'll
drag and drop input dialog box
enter a title let's say We'll enter it
as
uipath orchestrator
enter the input labels
to enter it as enter your name
let the input type B as text box
let's create a variable
say We'll name it as name
and let the variable type be string and
the scope is in the SQL score
we have created the variable so the
value entered should be of the variable
here
now we'll drag and drop a message box
from this set should be displayed
so you enter a caption for the message
say wait welcome
and enter the text
let's say hi
and we need to concatenate it with the
variable names
we'll say thanks for
watching
this video
so here we go we have created a workflow
now we need to publish this in the
orchestrator so you can see our option
here called publish click on the publish
button so you can see the package name
the version
the new version
and all the other things click on the
publish button
so the workflow is successfully
published so the name is blank
processary and version is 1.0.60
so let's go to the
orchestrator
in orchestrator
go to the my workflow
folder context and just go to my
packages
if you go here we can see refresh here
so here you can see blank process 3. so
process what we did now it was published
three minutes ago
let's go to the process
and the version
what we published was 1.0.16
so
the name was blank process three let's
start the job
you can change the job priority we'll
keep it as normal the other things is
default the process name and the job
type let's say let's execute this
process one time
click on start
as you can see command sent for blank
processing
so here you can see it is getting run
here you can see
it is asking for uipath orchestrator
what we entered the title and enter your
name
let's enter some name say sam
please click ok
so Hi Sam thanks for watching this video
now you go the message is being
displayed
like normally in uipath studio we click
on the Run button and run the workflow
but here we have published it in the
orchestrator and through the
orchestrator through the robot we are
running it and the message is displayed
what is framework and its purpose
the framework is indented to serve as a
blueprint for users to create process
that provide at a bare minimum a way to
store interpret and easily change
project configuration data as well as
robot exception handling scheme and
event logging for all exceptions and
related transaction information
the system locks messages at each
relevant stage in the process of
resolving a business transaction and
sends those logs to the orchestrator
server this in turn can be linked to the
elk stack which is elasticsearch log
stack and kibana platform which allows
for data storage and a variety of
different ways to represent the data
the purpose of our framework is to
resolve a set of business transaction
a transaction is a small amount of data
and the steps needed to process it to
complete a segment of business process a
process that reads a single email from a
mailbox and extracts data from it is a
good example
what is a business process
the sum of actions by which the data
required for a series of transactions is
collected processed and input into or
out of an IT resource is referred to as
a business process
we can classify business process into
three groups based on the steps involved
and how they are repeated linear the
steps of linear process are only done
once and if different data needs to be
processed the automation must be run
again
iterative the steps of iterative process
are repeated several times but different
data items are used every time
transactional transactional systems like
iterative process have steps that
replicate several times over various
data objects
what is re framework
the robotic Enterprise framework is a
state machine based project template
the template includes several
ready-to-use State containers for
launching applications retrieving data
processing it and closing the
transaction
these states are linked together by a
series of transactions that cover almost
every requirement in a typical
automation scenario
several workflows have been triggered
Each of which deals with a different
aspect of project
it's designed to incorporate all of the
industries best practices for logging
exception management application
initialization and other areas showing
it to handle even the most complex
business situations
let's look at the features of re
framework the three features are
settings logging and business
application exception
settings
during the initialization phase of
several process some configuration
settings and configuration values are
frequently read
like URLs to the web application
orchestrator queue names and default
logging messages diary framework
maintains a track of this information by
reading it from a configuration file and
storing it in a different dictionary
object shared by all states instead of
updating workflows directly this
provides a simple way to manage projects
by adjusting values in the configuration
file
login
the built-in locking mechanism is
another helpful feature of re framework
a majority of system workflows use log
message activities to Output information
about what is happening at each stage of
execution
this can be used to not only identify
problems and Aid in the debugging
process but also to generate
visualization and reports about the
process execution like how many invoices
are handled every day how many failures
occur and what dot the critical causes
of this value
business and application execution
there may be conditions that occur
during the execution of most process
that are not part of the usual execution
flow and must be resolved to achieve
more efficient automation
if the issue can be resolved by
restarting application the framework
will do so automatically and attempt to
process the transaction again search
exceptions are known as application
exception
if the issue is with the data or an
underlying business requirement the
system skips the transaction and moves
to the next search exception are known
as business exception
let's look at the re framework
architecture
the Rd framework is implemented as a
stake machine which is a form of
workflow with two advantageous
characteristics States and transitions
actions to be taken in response to the
stated input are described by States
transitions that switch the execution
from one state to another based on the
results of the state there are four key
States in re framework that is initial
State get transaction data process
transaction and end process
initial State initialization this is the
point at which the procedure begins it's
an event where the process initializes
the settings and runs application test
to ensure that all of the prerequis
sites for the process start are met
so initialization transitions so there
are two transition system exception and
successful when system exception when a
system error is not nothing it gets
transitioned to the end process if we
have an application exception during the
initialization phase we don't have
enough details to start the process as a
result we are going to the end process
state to wrap it up
successful when a system error is
nothing it gets transitioned to get
transaction data if during the
initialization we have no error then we
go to the get transaction data
the next state is the get transaction
state this state retrieves the next
transaction object this can be a q item
or a collection item
transcription items are Q items by
default but this can be modified to meet
your needs this is also the state where
the developer can set the condition to
exit the state when there are no items
to process
get transaction data transitions there
are two transitions no data and new
transaction
no data if the transaction item is
nothing then we are at the end of our
data collection so we go to the end
process
new transaction data if the transaction
item contains data then we process it
next state is the process transaction
state
the process transaction State for the
transaction item obtained in the
previous step it performs actions and
applies logic in various application if
a transaction item has been processed
the process moves on to the next
transaction item that is available
so there are three process transaction
transitions success business exception
and system exception in success if the
condition is business rule exception is
nothing and System error is nothing then
the transition to get transaction data
if there is a business rule exception it
is logged and we move on to the next
transition
business exception if the business rule
exception is not nothing then it gets
transitioned to get transaction data if
we have a business rule exception we log
it and move to the next transaction by
going to the get transaction data State
system exception if you have an
application exception we close all
programs kill them if they fail to
complete take a screenshot at the moment
the exception happened and go to init
where we reinitialize our working
environment and begin a new form of
transaction that has failed and finally
we have the end process State the
procedure is completed and the
application open during the automation
are closed in the end process State
since this is the last state the final
State there are no transition available
in the end process state
we'll explore each one of the states in
detail in the demo let's see the demo
now
in this demo we will see how to dispatch
data from the Excel file then we will
create queue items and process these
items and then we will understand the
working of each state in the robotic
Enterprise framework in detail
so let's get started first we will go to
the orchestrator and create a queue
Intel Cloud platform
dot UI
sign up then
go to the orchestrator
the tenant which you have created
select the folder context go to the
folder context and you can see queues
here go to the queues and you can see a
option to add here click on ADD
and enter a q name
[Music]
or later it has ref
enter any description if you want give
unique reference yes and add
and you can see a queue has been added
so you can add an asset as well to add
an asset you can go to add
click here add
and enter the asset name
[Music]
and select the type
whatever is required so Boolean
entity by default delete as false will
create
so this is how you create an asset
so let's go to the UI path Studio so
what we are basically doing is we are
building two process one to feed a queue
in the orchestrator that is a dispatcher
process and one to process transaction
from the queue that is using the robotic
Enterprise framework
so in dispatcher process what we do is
we get entries from an Excel file and
add them as a q items in the
orchestrator we have already created a
queue we started project as a sequence
and added a tri-cat we started with the
sequence added a try catch activity in
the try block
we use the retrench activity to read
first 10 lines
from A1 to C11 from an Excel file and
store them in a newly created data table
variable
we used for each row to Loop through the
rows of the data table variable and add
each of them in a queue using the add Q
item activity
then we use the log message
use log message activity to lock the
fact that the dispatching process was
successful
that is how we created the dispatcher
process
now we'll create a performer
using robotic Enterprise framework what
it does is it get Titans from the queue
and processes them
so
[Music]
in the dispatcher process let's go to
the initialization State first
so we will understand initialization
state in detail so the entire inner
block is kept inside the try catch
if you go to the documents here
and if you go to the data folder you can
see a config file here
so config file this is the file we use
in the init state it has three sheets
settings constants and assets
you can give any values whatever you
want for maximum retry number the value
should be 0. when you're working with
orchestrator queues the value should be
0. so this config file is stored in the
data folder
and it has three sheet settings
constants and assets
this is the Q name process a b c q or
let's get back to the end
framework
so we are initializing system error if
the error is nothing it will go to the
next state if first run read local
configuration file you can see by
default there are many variables created
you should know them and utilize them
whenever required
the config variable the value type is
dictionary type config is nothing
if you go here
you can see a config is nothing
initially there is no value so initially
config is nothing then it will invoke
init all settings workflow
so open this first run
so it will invoke in it all settings
workflow to see this workflow click on
open workflow it has three arguments
plus three arguments in config file in
config sheets and out config
this is of type string type string and
out config is of type dictionary
and Direction This is a both are input
and this is out
let's open the workflow and understand
so basically what this workflow does is
this workflow outputs setting dictionary
with the key value pairs to be used in
the project
settings are referred from the local
config file and then fetched from the
orchestrator assets assets will override
the config file settings
you need all settings workflow invoked
to initialize all settings and data for
application and process used in this
part the setting consent and Assets in
the config file from the data folder are
read in the initialize all settings
so let's go back to the orchestrator
queue name from the from the
configuration file in the argument case
we specified and it provides a backward
compatibility
next we have invo kill process
if we go to the arguments here
we can see the orchestrator Q name you
can assign a queue name here if you have
created a queue
so info kill process
next we have invoke Hill process it is
logging activity called killing process
depending on the project you can add
actively it is a logging activity called
killing process depending on the project
you can add activities
and and log fields in analog Fields if
you want to add any details in the log
file then you can do do it using all log
Fields any tall applications
workflow in this workflow invoke to open
apps and check the status credentials
and so on
and that there are two transitions in
this when it is successful it gets
transition to get transaction data when
there is a system exception it goes to
the end process
so
so in short what initialization state
does is at the end of this workflow that
is initialization state it reads the
config file and stores the key and value
inside the dictionary that is the out
config out config dictionary variable
has all config Excel file data
let's see the get transaction data
when you are in the orchestrator and you
want to immediately stop a job from for
some reason when a job is stopped this
activity gets activated
there is a variable created should stop
if it's a Boolean variable by default
it's false when it gets activated the
value becomes yes then it will go to the
log stop message as stop process
requested
and it will end the process when the
transaction item is nothing
else it will go to the try get
transaction data
here there it has seven arguments
and let's see the workflow invoke get
transaction data workflow
click on open workflow
it gets the data from the spreadsheets
databases email web API or uipath server
use if no new data items then set out
data section item to nothing
if a new transaction item is retrieved
then it gets additional information
about it it gives the condition where
our transaction item is not nothing then
it will add the transaction information
to the log fields
it is about defect transaction data
workflow
it process transaction State the process
is a sequence with a try catch Activity
Set to catch both system exceptions and
business exceptions
inside the type block the process
transaction workflow invoke that has
simple process like to attach the UI
demo application and three type into
activities to fill in and click accept
button
and if you see look at the transitions
it has three transition system exception
whose destination is the initialization
State business exception goes back to
the get transaction data and success it
goes to the get transaction data
finally the end process state where the
applications is closed what is web
automation
the concept of allowing software robots
to do predefined actions activities and
procedures on a web browser or an online
application is known as web automation
web automation can help with the
operations like form filling screen
scraping data extraction and transfer
across apps websites and testing and
periodic report preparation
features of web Automation in uipath
uipath is compatible with all webs it is
compatible with HTML Ajax Java
Silverlight and PDF
automated data entry data entry from an
Excel spreadsheet to website can be
automated in uipath
it provides simple web testing without
any programming knowledge uipath helps
in designing a valid test
no coding is required we can create
automation with a simple to use
graphical workflow designer
playback Precision uipath provides
hundred percent playback Precision web
automation can be done regardless of the
browser version screen position or size
how does web automation work in uipath
a built-in recorder in uipath web
automation can read and Implement
web-based activities
it uses attributes to identify web items
and manipulates them accurately while
keeping up with paid changes
it can be used with any website no
matter how sophisticated and can be
installed remotely through the network
the graphical workflow editor is simple
to use and does not require any coding
knowledge it's something that any user
with no programming experience can do
you save time and money by automating
web-based workflows with uipath
let's look at the demo
so in this demo we will scrape data from
the simply learns website we'll go to
Simply learns website
so consider a scenario where a customer
wants to know details about a particular
course
suppose if I want to know all the UI
path related resources that are present
on the website so I'll search as uipath
and I'll select all free resources that
are available on the website
so here you can see there are 27 results
27 free resources available on the
simply runs website so I'll scrape all
of this data so using data scraping
option in uipath I'll scrape the
resource name along with the type
whether it's an article or video
tutorial and along with that I'll scrape
the URL so I'll scrape all these three
things and copy it in the Excel sheet
and the Excel sheet over and mail I'll
send it to the custom
so let's get started so let's jump into
uipath studio and get started with the
demo so let's create a new flowchart
we'll name the flowchart as web
automation
since we are
showing this demo under web automation
so a new flowchart is created so in this
flowchart we will drag and drop a
sequence activity
right click
right click and select as set as start
mode
so open the sequence
and drag and drop an open browser
activity
in the open browser activity select the
browser type
select the whichever browser you want
I'll select Chrome
and one more thing you need to do is
go to home go to tools and install the
uipath extensions click on Chrome
and if you want to continue installing
your path extension for Chrome please
close all your Chrome process then click
on OK so then click on OK and your UI
path extension
for Chrome will get installed
so since I have already installed I'll
click on cancel
when after installing when you open
Chrome so your screen will look like
this so where you have to enable the
extension click on enabling extension
and the Chrome extension will be
installed in your device
okay so let's come back to UI path
studio so select the open browser select
the browser where you want to get it
installed so let's create a variable
here
let's create a variable as website URL
let's go to variable and enter the URL
so let's go to the
simply launch website
and copy the URL
once the URL is copied so this open
browser activity is a container that
enables you to open a browser at a
specified URL and execute multiple
activities with within it
so we have selected the open browser so
inside the open browser activity we will
drag and drop maximize window activity
maximize window it maximizes the
indicated window
so after this next we need to drag and
drop type into activity
so we'll drag and drop
type into activity
bring it outside
bring it outside the open browser
indicate on the screen the first thing
is we need to select the search bar
so we'll select the search bar for and
what we are entering here is UI paths
since we are searching for UI path cores
so enter UI path
and after entering uipath we need to
click on enter
so we need to enter to search the UI
path related resources so click on this
plus button and select the enter option
select enter
so separate this concatenated
okay so this is the
so once in the browser after entering
uipath
the next thing we need to do is click on
this free resources click on this all
option check this box so for that what
we have to do is
search for click option click activity
and select this click activity
indicate on screen
and select this click
so this is done
next thing what we need to do is when we
click here on all we find 27 results so
when we do it automatically when the bot
does is when the robot does this thing
it does not go down and refresh all the
results what it does is when it opens
this page without loading the below
results how much our results are
available some 10 results it will copy
only those 10 results it will not
refresh and copy the results which are
below
so for that what we have to do is
we'll go to uipath Studio we will select
drag and drop one more type into
activity
and will indicate on screen
will scroll down
till the bottom
and will simply select this blank
screen
just because so that the every time the
robot comes into this page it goes till
the bottom and copies all the results
that is why we select simply a blank
screen here and
it is showing an error we have to enter
something here so we'll select the
command say since we are scrolling it
down we'll select down and this much is
done
so go back to the flowchart
which we have created automation
and we'll drag and drop a new sequence
so till here it's done
where we are opening the simply launch
website and searching for uipath
next we what we'll do is we will
scrape the data
so we will rename it as data scraping
will open this sequence so data scraping
is something where we extract structured
data from a browser application or a
document to a data table so we'll click
on data scraping
so we'll open the browser so we have
opened the browser now we'll select the
data which we want to extract so click
on next
scroll up
so first we'll select the resource name
so we'll select top UI path interview
questions to create a pattern we need to
indicate a similar field preferably the
last in the collection
or the second one so what we'll do is
we'll select the second one
and we can create a column and we'll
name the column as resources
if you want you can take the URL
we'll take the URL before that will take
the type so these are the resources for
27 resources
if the maximum number of results it will
go to is 100 if we enter 100 year if you
want more than 100 you can remove this
100 and keep it as 0 so it will select
all 0 for all
so after this will extract correlated
data
this time we will extract the type
whether it's an article or it's the
video tutorial click on article
and indicate the similar field for the
next one we'll select video tutorial
so this column will name it as type
and we'll extract the URL of each
resource and we will name the column as
say
link links okay next
and we are done so enter on finish
this data spanning multiple pages
in our case there is no multiple Pages
there is only one page in case if there
are multiple Pages you can click on yes
here press s to indicate it scroll down
and select the next pages
but since in this page there is only one
page so we'll click on no
okay this much is done we have scraped
data so after the data scraping is done
we want to copy the script data into an
Excel sheet so to copy it in the Excel
sheet we need Excel application scope
so we'll search for Excel application
scope activity
so Excel application scope activity
opens an Excel workbook providing a
scope for Excel activities when this
activity ends the workbook and Excel
applications are closed if this
specified file does not exist a new
Excel file is created so for this Excel
application scope so we'll go to desktop
go to new and create a new Microsoft
Excel worksheet we'll name it as
uipath
UI part details
so we have created a file
we'll go back to the uipath studio
now we'll select the file which we had
created
you go to desktop and select the file UI
part details and we'll click on open
next we will drag and drop right range
activity
we'll search for
right range activity
bring it inside the do
and by default it is sheet 1 and A1
so right range activity writes the data
from a data table in a spreadsheet
starting from the cell
if the starting cell isn't specified the
writing begins at A1 cell
so once that is done
now we need to enter the variable that
is extract data table variable which we
extracted here that is this variable
extract data table
we need to enter this variable
go here and
search for extract data table variable
so this much is done we have scraped
data from the simply launch website then
using the Excel application scope we
have written the data in the Excel sheet
so let's run till here and see whether
it's clapping the data and writing in
the Excel sheet
so we'll save it and click on run
so let's see we'll close this
here you can see it's opening the simply
learns website
entering UI path oops we have made an
error okay let's go and let's stop here
so we had made an error here the bracket
was missing it is why now we have
corrected it let's save and run
for that close this
it's opening the simple lunch website it
will enter UI path select all the free
resources then it will copy this in the
Excel sheet
you can see it's copying
so let's open the Excel worksheet which
we created and let's check if it has
copied so you can see in the Excel file
which we had created
the data has been scraped and copied
here
the First Column it is the
course name or the resource name which
we had copied and the second column it
is the type whether it is an article or
video tutorial in the third column it is
the URL there are no headers here right
we can give the headers so we'll go to
the uipath studio
and if you click on Excel application
scope or write range here you can see
add headers so click here and the
address will be added in the Excel sheet
so that's much is done now next step is
we need to send this Excel file over and
mail so to send this Excel file over and
mail let's go to activities let's drag
and drop a new sequence
we'll use a separate sequence to send
the activities over a mail
sorry not here
user subject
we'll connect this
will name this activity as
main since we are sending it our mail
open this sequence
the first activity we need here is get
password activity
so search for get password
drag and drop it get password activity
encrypts a password by associating it
with the current user only workflows
running under the current user context
can decrypt the password so go to the
password and enter your email ID
password
foreign
create a new variable and store the
password in a variable so that your
password is encrypted and name the
variable as
word short form something password
and next activity we need is send SMTP
mail message
so double click on send SMTP mail
message
so this activity basically sends an
email message by using the SMTP protocol
so go to the port and enter the port
which is 587
and go to the server and enter the
server
SMTP
dot gmail.com
and enter the email ID to which you want
to
send the mail
okay
enter the password
the password variable which we had
created enter that and enter the email
ID here as well
so enter the subject of the mail what
what you want the subject to be
so I'll name it as course details
and enter the body
so I'll enter a simple hello
here are the details
okay
so there is a prerequisite for this uh
you have to to receive for to send an
email you have to go to your Google
account that is the email account
security option and there you have to
turn on secured access go to the option
called secured access and turn it on
okay next we need to attach the file the
file which we want to send it over and
mail attach the file in which we had
scraped the data from the simply learns
website
so let's go to web automation the
previous sequence and copy the file path
from the Excel application screen
so we'll copy this file path
and
go back
in the attach file
we will
paste this path
move one double quote
click on OK
next we'll drag and drop a message box
just for like our reference to show a
message so that the process is completed
so we'll enter a simple message in the
message box like the course details have
been made successfully
so correct let me correct the spelling
details okay
so now there are no errors so now the
project is complete
so what I have done is I have taken a
flowchart in the flowchart I've taken a
first sequence and this sequence I am
opening the browser the simply learns
browser I'm maximizing it then I am not
type using the type into activity I am
recording the search bar in the search
bar I am entering the UI python clicking
on enter so after clicking on enter I'll
select the all option where I'll select
all the resources
diff first sequence then in the second
sequence I am scraping the data
in scraping data option I'll scrape the
data I'll skip the course name the type
and the URL then in the Excel
application scope I'll copy all the
scrape data in an Excel file so I'll use
an Excel application scope I have
created a file so in that file I'll
write describe data
in the second sequence then finally in
the third sequence I am using the get
password activity and send SMTP mail
message and I am sending it over an
email I am sending the Excel file as an
attachment with an email to the custom
model this message box simply indicates
that the mail has been successfully sent
okay now let me save and click on run
so I'll close the previous browser
let me save and click on run
web automation execution is started it
is going to the browser
we're going to Simply learn website
search for UI path click on all
resources
and it's copying the resources in an
Excel sheet
after copying the resource in an Excel
sheet it is sending over an email so it
has sent over an email and the message
has been displayed the course details
have been successfully mailed let me go
to my email inbox and check whether I
have received it
so let me click on course detail have
been made successfully Let me refresh
and here you can see I have received the
mail let me open this file
so here you can see I've received the
file which consists of resources the
type and the link
what is Excel automation
pixel automation is a task for
automation involving Excel files Studio
X enables the creation of automation
project involving various types of data
from an Excel file using various
specialized activities to create an
Excel automation we must use Excel file
resource when creating a new project
that includes Excel an Excel file must
be specified within it so that all of
the subsequent actions can access the
data contained within that file
why use an Excel automation
UI path allows you to automate excel in
various ways such as Excel application
scope activities and workbook activities
Excel automation simplifies your
application by performing tasks such as
formatting cells updating values and
running macros automatically Excel tasks
in automated process can also be
integrated with several other functions
across the Enterprise using an RPS
solution the benefit of excel Automation
in general is that it can save people
many are spent manually completing tasks
advantages of excel automation
productivity Excel automation provides
higher production rates and increased
productivity efficiency some of the
functions of excel can easily create
automated tasks and custom logic with
functions like macros macros are an
excellent way to save time on
predictable repetitive tasks hence Excel
automation is efficient
better product quality Axel automation
improves quality in several ways
including eliminating human error
increasing consistency and accuracy the
ability to create more complex projects
and the detection of mistakes along the
way
improved safety Excel allows you to
protect your work whether it's to
prevent someone from opening a workbook
without a password to Grant read-only
access to a workbook or to Simply
preserve a worksheet so you don't delete
any data
reduced labor Excel automation will
perform all the repetitive tasks more
accurately and productively than humans
thus reduces labor reduce lead time a
lead time is the amount of time that
elapses between the start and finish of
a process Excel automation reduces the
lead time
let's look how to install an Excel
package let's jump into the uipath
studio to install an Excel package go to
the manage packages
you can see the packages that are
installed go to all packages and search
for uipath Excel activities
by default an updated version will be
installed if the Excel package is not
installed you can install it from here
so in my device this activity is already
installed
so this is the place from where you can
install any activities or any packages
let's see some of the commonly used
Excel activities
these are some of the commonly used
Excel activities redrain select range
save workbook autofill range copy paste
strain insert and delete columns so
insert inserting a column at the
specified location in a sheet or a table
or a range
and to delete a column you can delete it
from a specified range or the table
there are filters filter table so what
filters does is you can use the filter
action to create a filter in a Range
table or a sheet based on the values in
a single column we also have vlookup
vlookup which stands for vertical lookup
is an Excel feature that when enabled
searches and retrieves data from a
specified column we will explore all of
these activities in the demo section in
detail
let's look at the demo in this demo we
have an Excel sheet that has a record of
covet cases in five states of India in
so we will create an Excel automation to
represent the number of cases in charge
it's easy to understand looking at the
charts rather than looking at the huge
numbers
then we will upload the file on the
drive
so let's jump into the uipath studio and
get started
this is the Excel file which I have
created
it has all the number of cases in this 5
States in the year 2021 in the month of
Jan Feb March and April all this record
I have taken it from a website called
prsindia.org
thank you
so I have two sheets sheet 1 and Sheet
two
so let's jump into the UI path Studio
to start off with the demo we need to
have the three packages installed
one is the UI path Excel activities
package and the other one is uipath G
Suite dot activities this activity this
package is used for Drive top load only
drive then
the other package is Bala River Excel
activities this package is used for bar
graph and pie chart
so
after installing these three packages
we'll get started
so let's create a new sequence
name it as sequence
so first we'll drag and drop an Excel
application scope
so Excel application scope what it does
is it opens an Excel workbook and sets
the scope for Excel activities when this
activity is completed the specified
workbook and the Excel application are
closed when your book application
variable is specified in the output
workbook activities field the
spreadsheet is not closed
after this drag and drop a create table
activity
so by default we have sheet1 and
enter the range
so the range is this Excel sheet ranges
from A1 to F5
so enter the range
for this
we need to enter the file path so we'll
select the file
so we have selected the file
we have entered the
enter the table name
say
a number of cases
[Music]
so once this much is done
next we'll drag and drop a bar chart
drop it outside the Excel application
scope and select the file path
so select the file
select this cell range that is the same
range what we had entered earlier
A1
to S5
so once that is the 50 chart title
say basis
and you can select the chart type
bar stack 3D clustered 3D styled
whatever is required
for now we'll select bar cluster
we have many other options to explore
all right
data label type
will keep it in
show value so that it shows the value
and select
show value
if you want to show percentage you can
select percentage
we'll select show Legend
and size
you can vary the size accordingly how
much hour you want
so I'll keep the sizes
350.
you can change the width
so the bar chart is done
and you can enter the sheet which sheet
are you using so it's sheet1
now we will drag and drop pie chart
select the file
similarly enter the options here
enter the cell range the same rate
A1 is to F5
show percent we will show value
show Limited
select show value
and select the sheet which you will
select the sheet to
so done so we have completed till here
next we need to upload this on the
Google Drive so we'll select this option
upload file
select the file
selected the file so select the
destination folder
for that
go to your Google Drive account
so we will go there
so in my drive I have created a folder
called Excel automation
so I'll copy this URL
till here for the entire
copy this
and go to your UI path studio and paste
it in the destination folder
this is a double quotes
then create a variable and
create a variable as file
oops there is an error we have forgotten
to use a g Suite application
this can be only used inside a g Suite
application
so drag and drop a g Suite application
and inside G Suite application
you will find this so here is called
so we'll run the file now
we'll save it
and run
you can see the file is getting
run
so the execution is ended
we will navigate
to the drive
so here you can see
the file is successfully uploaded will
open the file
it's working on the graph
here you go here you can see the bar
graph
for the sheet1 with the values
number of values and each state was and
for Sheet 2 we created a pie chart so
here we go where you can see the page
let's begin by understanding who is an
RPA developer
now generally speaking an RPA developer
is someone who works cross-functionally
with business operations and business
analysts to create and optimize workflow
processes
however this is a relatively new career
path and many organizations formal
titles for RPA developers differ
now other similar positions may include
titles like process designer or
automation architect but no matter the
title the role of a successful RPA
developer involves to design develop and
Implement RPA systems
in order to automate the business
process an RPA developer will be
required to create workflow diagrams and
strategically document the
implementation he is also responsible
for bug fixes so coding skills are
important now in order to be a
successful RPA developer you must have
the ability to navigate various
appropriate Technologies such as uipath
or automation anywhere
next up is RPS growth projections
now looking at the curve both RPS
software and services increased by huge
amounts between 2016 and 2020 and Beyond
according to next Wednesday research
knowledge and work automation could have
an economic impact of about five to
seven trillion US dollars for the year
2025. it will touch more than 230
million knowledge workers which
constitute up to nine percent of the
global Workforce now any company which
is labor intensive where people are
performing high volume High transaction
functions will boost their capabilities
and save money and time without you
now that we've established that RPA has
this steep growth curve let's look at
the RPA job roles that you should look
out for
we have the RPA developer senior RTA
developer RPA process architect RPA
developer senior consultant project
manager lead developer business analyst
and RPA data analyst
now these job roles come with specific
responsibilities depending on the
designation
however there are a few common
responsibilities of an RPA developer
let's go ahead and check them out
now the first one is strategic planning
skills now planning is a crucial phase
in any development life cycle the RPA
developer regardless of the designation
should possess the aptitude to ensure
strategic planning
planning includes the design development
and implementation of RPA systems this
also helps streamline the business
next up is strong analytical skills now
to understand the client's requirements
in cater to the needs accordingly is
crucial
analytical skills are also important to
predict or identify potential bugs and
errors and rectify them
now this skill is especially required if
you're involved in the overall
development
next we have strong problem solving
skills now this again is extremely
crucial to predict any outages and they
put the entire unit to overcome any
unforcing interruptions from the
business perspective as well problem
solving skills play a significant role
in ensuring smooth conduction of tasks
experience in any programming language
such as C C plus plus python Ruby Java
or dot net is also important
hands-on experience on RPA tools and
cognitive platforms such as blue prism
automation anywhere uipath open spam Etc
is necessary communication skills are
pivotal for any organization the
developer should be outspoken and
articulate any new ideas you should also
be confident to lose concerns and be as
transparent as possible in the long run
this only proves to be helpful to the
organization
lastly we had exposure to SQL now
experience with database with SQL or
nosql is highly preferred there's always
an added Advantage if you have the
knowledge about accessing and managing
databases
next up we have RPA developer Saturdays
now the salaries will differ depending
on the location your experience and also
the designation
now in the US here are the job salaries
and the roles according to Glassdoor an
RPA developer in the US earns around 76
000 US dollars per year
the NRP developer senior consultant
earns around 99 000 US dollars per year
an RPA process architect earns an
average salary of 95 000 US Dollars and
a senior RPA developer earns an average
salary of 92 000 US dollars
an RPA project manager earns around 73
000 US dollars per annum and RPA Lee
developer earns an average salary of 99
000 US dollars per annum nrpa business
analyst earns around 68 000 US dollars
per annum and the data analyst earns
around 62 000 US dollars per annum
moving on to India the average salary of
an RPA developer is around 5 lakhs 98
000 rupees that offers senior consultant
a senior RK developer and an rpu lead
developer is around 14 lakhs per annum
rupees
now let me quickly run you through a
sample resume of an RPA developer now
this is just a template and you can
alter it according to your needs first
up is your general information like name
phone number and your email ID
then you can give a quick description
about yourself and your strengths you
can also mention the objective as to why
you're applying and what you're looking
for in the organization
you can include your LinkedIn profile
link and your GitHub link one look at
your LinkedIn profile is enough for
anybody to gather all the information
necessary so make sure that is updated
moving on you could mention your
experience now here you would have to
mention the names of your previous
organizations along with your
designation and the tenure
you could also include your key
responsibilities in these organizations
along with the responsibilities you
could also mention the awards that you
received in your organizations
next up is your educational background
you can mention the university that you
graduated from and is required that you
have a degree in computer science you
can also go ahead and mention your GPA
the next section is skills now this is
pretty cliche in the technical skill
section you could mention about
different RPA tools that you've worked
on if you're good at a particular
programming language go ahead and
mention that as well
as mentioned earlier any experience in
database management is an added
advantage
if you have any experience go ahead and
mention that moving on to non-technical
skills you could mention any
extracurricular activities that you're
proud of some soft skills that you feel
worth mentioning can be added in this
section mentioning the languages that
you know can also boast your resume
now given all this it's fundamental that
you do not lie on your resume
alright then with that we conclude this
session I hope it gave you a clear
understanding of the subject uipath
assist business in successfully
automating their business process
if you are planning to attend an
interview for an RPA or uipath developer
role here is a comprehensive list of
most frequently Asked uipath interview
questions with answers
what is uipath this question looks
simple but people most of the time end
up giving wrong definition
uipath is a robotic process automation
tool for large scale end-to-end
automation
for an accelerated business change it
provides solution for business to
automate routine office activities
it uses a variety of methods to
transform tedious tasks into automated
process
what are the different components in
uipa uipath consists of three components
mainly uipath studio uipath studio is a
user-friendly interface that allows
users to visually plan and design
various automation process through
diagrams using the drag and drop
functionality
these diagrams are merely a structural
reflection of specific tasks that must
be completed
uipath robot after you have built your
process the next move is to put into
action in the uipath studio
UI path robots are used to translate the
strategies into tasks which are then
executed
these robots are used to assign various
tasks and carry them out in the same
manner as humans but without human
interference
when given an operation occurs on the
computer they program uipath robots to
begin executing task automatically
uipath orchestrator the orchestrator is
a web-based application in uipath it has
features for deploying monitoring
scheduling and controlling automated
boards and process it's a centralized
forum for managing and maintaining all
software Bots
what are the different workflows in
uipath
sequences a sequence is a small type of
project that is best suited for linear
process it enables developers to
transition from one activity to another
easily they can be reused numerous times
flowchart it can be used for large or
small projects that help in development
of complex business and connecting
activities in a variety of ways
flowcharts assist in the presentation of
multiple branches of logical operators
State machine
a state machine is a machine that uses a
certain number of states for automation
during execution it will only change
States if an action is performed on it
let's look at the next question
what is a uipath robot
the robot is a UI path execution agent
allowing you to run process created in
the studio
in order to execute process robots must
be connected to the orchestrator or
licensed locally
what are the different components of
uipath robot
service the robot service is the primary
controller for all operations it
communicates with Studio the robot agent
and the robot command line interface by
an inter-process Communication channel
to receive and process information
executor the robot executor is the
component that is directly responsible
for process execution the robot service
creates a robot executor instance every
time a job is started
command line interface
the robot command line interface is a
console application that starts jobs and
waits for their results
uipath assistant is a tool designed
specifically to improve the user's
interaction with our robots from the
comfort of the desktop it is where users
can easily access manage and run
automation with a few clicks
what is the difference between attended
and unattended robot
attended robots are supervised robots
that humans operate
they work on the same workstation as a
human user and is triggered by user
events
unattended robots
unattended robots are those that do not
require human supervision to perform
tasks they run in Virtual environments
without human control and can automate
any number of process
what are the features of uipath
drag and drop workflow the UI path user
will develop visual process steps by
dragging and dropping related tasks onto
the graphical workspace then with the
user interface properties they can
transform these process steps into a
visual workflow users may also use the
recorder wizard in the uipath tool to
build web-based or application workflow
record and Playback the user can use
this function to record actions and
transform them into an automated process
series
inbuilt activities in uipath uipath
comes with over 300 built-in activities
covering a wide range of process
Automation and application integrated
design task
you can find these activities in
activities pane which covers most design
tasks such as data extraction data entry
and automation
Advanced scraping options scraping data
from web pages and applications is more
accessible with uipath screen scraping
furthermore the data scraping wizard
helps in the scraping of data with a
repetitive structure scraping solution
Works flawlessly with any program
including.net Java flash PDF Legacy and
sap
high security and robustness you can
create super smart durable robots with
uipath visual canvas everyone in the
company can use these boards uipath
offers high security Auto login
functionality to run the Bots and
operates with a locked screen allowing
automated process to run in complete
privacy
what are the different recording options
in uipath
basic recording it focuses on automating
single tasks and is commonly used to
develop each activity's complete
selector
desktop recording it can be used for a
variety of actions as well as
application development
web recording web recording is a
standard tool for viewing and recording
web activities
Citrix recording it is very widely used
for recording stuff like pictures and
virtualized environment automation
what is a managed package in uipath
the package manager functionality allows
to download activities packages
libraries Frameworks wrappers and others
and View and update the ones already
installed for the project and add and
remove it
it displays the list of available
packages per feed and a list of
dependencies for the current project
the manage package Windows always opens
with the project dependencies list
how to publish a project in uipath
to publish a project in uipath first
create a new project
then in the design ribbon tab click
publish the publish window will open
in the package properties tab enter the
name for package then click next in the
publish options tab select the location
where you want to publish your project
and finally the information dialog box
displays so let's see a demo
how is it done
so let's jump in the uipath studio
so here we are in uipath studio
it's open overflow
I'll drag and drop a simple message box
just to show
enter a message say
hey
so I have created a simple workflow just
to show you how to publish project in
uipath
so here you can see the publish option
once you have created the project go to
the ribbon Tab and click on the publish
when you click the publish window opens
here you can change the package name if
you want you can see the version new
version package icon and release notes
so let's click on next
where you will get the custom URL
where you want to publish to
then click on publish
here you go you can see publishing
package
so a info dialog box appears project
published successfully
if you want you can copy to the
clipboard
so this is how the project is published
in the UI path
what is data scraping and Screen
scraping
data scripting is the process of
extracting structured data from a
browser application or document and
saving it to a database or a DOT CSV
file or even an Excel spreadsheet
screen scraping methods are activities
that allow data to be extracted from a
specific UI element or document such as
a DOT PDF file
explain the different types of
Automation in uipath
Excel automation Excel automation is a
useful tool for sorting deleting
retrieving and analyzing data it is
simple to migrate and integrate data
into platforms
Studio X has a strong integration with
Microsoft Excel and ships with several
activities that automate Excel tasks
mail automation enables task automation
with emails from the Outlook desktop
application Gmail and Outlook 365. add
the activities that use data from the
account inside the resource activity
after adding the account to the
automation as a resource using a used
Outlook 365 use Gmail or use desktop
Outlook app activity
word Automation in the word automation
add the word document to be worked on by
using a word file activity and then add
the word activities to automate within
the use Word file
PowerPoint automation
PowerPoint automation allows the user to
automate the most common task in
PowerPoint presentation add the
presentation to work with the use
PowerPoint presentation activity and
then inside the use PowerPoint
presentation add the presentation
activities to automate
file automation it refers to the
automation of tasks performed on your
computer with files and folders such as
creating copying or renaming files and
folders
Studio X includes several activities
that automate tasks that you perform
with files and folders
CSC automation
in CSV automation add the CSV activities
inside the use Excel file activity where
the Excel file is defined to move data
between CSV and Excel
explain a few read and write activities
read range retrange reads the values of
an Excel range and stores in a data
table variable read cell reads the
values of an Excel cell and stores in a
variable
read CSV reads all entries from a
specified CSV file right range writes
data from a data table variable to a
spreadsheet
right cell writes a value or formula
into a specified spreadsheet cell
write CSP overwrites a specified data
table to a CSV file
what is an Excel application scope
Excel application scope opens an Excel
workbook and sets the scope for Excel
activities
when this activity is completed the
specified workbook and Excel application
are closed
what is an orchestrator
uipath orchestrator is a web application
that orchestrates the execution of
repetitive process
it manages the creation monitoring
scheduling and controlling of bots and
process
it can manage the entire robot Fleet
name some orchestrator capabilities
provisioning provisioning establishes
and maintains the connection between the
robots and the web application
deployment ensures that it delivers the
correct package versions to the assigned
robots for execution
configuration looks after the
maintenance and delivery of robot
environments and process configuration
cues cues ensures that it automatically
distributes the workload across robots
monitoring manages user permissions and
keeps track of robot recognition details
logging
logs are stored and indexed in an SQL
database
explain process job asset and queue
the process page allows you to build a
new process from uploaded packages
managing existing process and keep all
of your process up to date with the
latest package version
jobs on a new iPath robot a job
represents the execution of procedure it
can start the execution of job in either
attended or unattended mode
use a queue is a storage container that
can accommodate an infinite number of
objects multiple types of data such as
invoice information or customer data are
stored in queue objects other systems
such as sap or Salesforce are used to
process this data
assets assets are usually shared
variables or credentials that can be
used through several automation projects
they allow you to store unique
information that the robots can easily
access
how to connect a robot to the
orchestrator
Step 1 open UI path assistant
Step 2 sign in the uipath orchestrator
step 3 create a tenant
step 4 connect the robot to the
orchestrator
and step 5 check the status it shows
connected and licensed
so let's see a demo of how to do this so
let's jump into the uipath studio
open you step 1 open UI path assistant
so we'll open UI path assistant
after opening uipath assistant login to
the uipath orchestrator
so go to the browser
go to the browser and type
platform.uipart.com this will take to
the uipath website
so sign in if you're new to this if you
don't have the account then you can
enter all the details and login
since I have already created an account
I'll sign in
after logging in the uipath orchestrator
go to the admin
here you can create a new tenant
you can add a tenant here and create a
new tenant since I have already created
a tenant named admin
so after creating a tenant connect the
robot to the orchestrator
go to the uipath assistant
go to preferences
go to orchestrator settings
here you can see the status it is
offline
click on the sign in button
once you click on the sign in button
allow this open uipath
and here you can see it is connecting
and you can see if it is connected and
license
so the UI path robot is now connected
with the orchestrator
what is a tenant context and folder
context
in current context to view and control
tenant level entities in the
orchestrator pick tenant from the
sidebar menu with only one instance of
the orchestrator multi-tenancy allows
isolating data
for the folder context from the sidebar
menu pick any available folder to view
and control the entities within the data
folder
so I'll show you let's go to the
orchestrator
so
let's go to the orchestrator
here you can see this is the tenant
context
who grew and control the tenant level
entities in orchestrator you can pick
the tenant from the sidebar menu
from the sidebar menu pick any available
folder so these are the folders pick any
available folder to view and control the
entities within that folder so this is
with respect to the folder context
what is an re framework
the robotic Enterprise framework is a
state machine based project template
it allows to handle even the most
complex business situations it's
designed to incorporate all of the
industries best practices for logging
exception management application
initialization and other areas
what are the features of re framework
settings during the initialization phase
of several process some configuration
settings and configuration values are
frequently read like URLs to a web
application orchestrator queue names and
default login messages
login
the built-in locking mechanism is
another helpful feature of the framework
the majority of the system's workflows
use log message activities to Output
information about what is happening at
each execution stage
business exception if the issue is with
the data or any underlying business
requirement the system skips the
transaction and moves on to the next
search exceptions are known as business
exceptions
application exception if the issue can
be resolved by restarting applications
the framework will do so automatically
and attempt to process the transaction
again search exceptions are known as
application exceptions
how to merge two Excel files into a
single Excel file
first we need to create a sequence
after creating a sequence we need a few
activities like read CSV activity assign
activity data table activity and write
CS file activity so we'll drag and drop
all these activities and do the process
then we will run the sequence and see
the output so let's jump into the uipath
studio and start with the workflow
[Music]
so we are in the UI path Studio
I have already created a sequence you
can go to new and create a sequence or
press Ctrl n
so after starting a sequence first we'll
drag and drop
read CSV activity
since we are using two Excel files so we
need to read CSV activity we'll drag and
drop another trick CSV activity
so we'll select the location of the
first Excel file
select the first Excel file
I'll show you both the Excel files which
we are merging so this is the first
Excel file so it has five rows five
names
so we'll this is the first Excel file
and
and this is the second Excel files this
Excel file has five different names
and the other Excel file has five
different rows
so these are the two Excel files will
merge both these Excel files into a
single new Excel file
so we'll close this Excel files
so in the first read CSV activity
we have copied the location of the first
Excel file in the output 2 we'll select
this and create a variable right click
and create a variable and let's say name
the variable as SL underscore 51
we have named the variable
okay now we'll
go to another read CSV file and select
the location of the second file
so I have downloaded this sample Excel
files from the internet
just for the demo
right click and create a variable
let's say name this variable as SL
underscore file to
so now that we have dragged and dropped
to read CSV activities now next we need
assign activity
so drag and drop a sign activity
so assign activity has two parameters as
you can see two and enter a VB
expression
in the two parameter in this right click
and create a variable
and name the variable
let's say merged
asset
so after naming the variable enter an
expression here
so enter the expression as
SL underscore file 1 which is the
variable for file one select this
and enter the expression dot clone
what is clone function does is the Clone
function creates a new data table with
the same structure but does not copy the
data so we are creating a new Excel file
that is the third file in which we are
merging the data tables of both the
Excel file so the third Excel file which
we are creating will have the same
structure as the Phi one so this Global
function creates a third Excel file with
the same structure as the file one so
it's showing an error so select this
assign
let's go to variables
here you can see variable type string
change it to system.data dot data table
and here you go letter is got
okay so now we have dragged and dropped
assign activity the next activity which
we need is merge data table activity
search for merge
data article activity
drag and drop
much readable activity
we need two much data table activity
since we have two Excel files
select the first merge data table
activity go to the destination
and enter the destination which is the
variable which we created in the assign
activity the merged essay
so
enter this
and enter the source file that is the
variable which you created in file one
that is SL underscore
file one similarly similarly go to merge
data table
and enter the same destination
but here the source will be the second
file
okay now that we have dragged and
dropped too much data tables the next
activity we need is a write CSV file
so we'll search for write CSV file
after dragging and dropping right CSV
activity
go to file path
and create a file
create a file say one will name it as
file
three
safety file
now that we have created the file we
will write from the data table that is
we need to copy the merge data table so
we'll enter
now that we have finished the program
the file is created let's save and run
it
foreign
so
let's go to the file
so this is the file which we created
let's open this file
and here you can see
both the Excel files have been merged
into a single Excel file let's go to the
next question how to send a file over a
main
so first create a sequence and create a
file after you have created a file drag
and drop get password activity
then drag and drop a SMTP made message
activity so basically these two
activities are used to send a file over
me then run the sequence so we'll jump
into the uipath studio and see
so this was the previous question which
we answered
how to merge to Excel files so the same
file we will send it over at mail
so we need a get password activity
so we'll drag and drop a get password
activity
so if you go to the properties section
enter the password to whichever email
you are sending this file enter the
password of that mail ID
[Music]
after entering the password in the
result go and create a variable
so that password is stored in that
variable so name the variable say
anything any randomly so I have named
the variable
after
after this you need a SMTP mail message
activity
so drag and drop send SMTP mail message
in SMTP email message
under the properties pane under the host
enter the port value
or report number which is 5 7.
sorry
after entering the port number go to the
server and enter it as SMTP
dot gmail.com
okay now after entering the email ID
go to your email and enter your email ID
to which you want to send this file
don't forget to use double quotes
otherwise it will show an error
enter the password
so we had showed the password in and
variable say SSS
so
we'll write that
so after that
enter the email ID here under the two
option
and enter the subject
to say it has demo since we are showing
a demo
we'll enter the subject as demo this is
the this subject and body is the subject
and body of the male
so
now let's attach the file which we have
created
copy the file location
so we'll go to the file
and copy this file location
after attaching the file
let's save and run
the process has started
and the process has rendered here you
can see in the output
the process has started and the process
has ended let's go over the main and
check if we have received
here we go we have received the file
let's open the file
and here you go the same this is the
same file which had merged the data so
the file has been sent over the main
one thing you have to keep in mind when
you use the get password activity go to
your Google account in the security
section
go to the secure app access and turn it
on
you have to turn it on to receive the
file over at email
explain the different states and
transitions in re framework
there are four key States in re
framework
the first state is initial State this is
the point at which the procedure begins
it's an event where the process
initializes the settings and runs
application test to ensure that all of
the prerequis sites for the process
start are met
next we have get transaction state
this state retrieves the next
transaction object this can be a q item
or a collection item transaction items
are queue items by default but this can
be modified to meet your needs this is
also when the developer can set the
condition to exit the state when there
are no items to process
process transaction state
for the transaction item obtained in
previous step it performs actions logic
in various application if a transaction
item has been processed the process
moves on to the next transaction item
available
in process state
the procedure is completed and the
applications open during automations are
closed in the end process state
let's jump into the uipath studio and
see the different transitions in robotic
Enterprise framework
so this is the robotic Enterprise
framework this is the initialization
state in the first state so it has two
transitions system error that is system
exception and successful
when it shows system exception when a
system error is not nothing it gets
transition to the end process suppose if
you have an application exception during
the initialization phase and we don't
have enough details to start a process
then as a result we are going to end
process state to wrap it up
and the successful is when a system
error is nothing it gets transition to
get transaction state
if during initialization we have no
error then it goes to the get
transaction data
the get transaction data has two
transitions
no data and new transaction no data is
when if the transaction item is nothing
then we are at the end of our data
collection so it goes to the end process
and in new transaction if the
transaction item contains data then it
processes it
the process transaction data has three
transitions
success business exception and system
exception success is when if the
condition is business rule exception is
nothing and system error is nothing then
the transition to get transaction data
if there is a business rule exception it
is logged and we move on to the next
transaction
and Rule exception is if the business
rule exception is not nothing then it
gets transaction to the get transaction
data and the end process does not have
any transitions since the end process is
the final state so there are no
transitions
what is a g Suite activity
the uipath G Suite activity package
helps in the automation of Google
workspace applications such as Google
Calendar Google Drive Google Sheets
Gmail Google Docs you can create and
modify Google calendar events manage
Google drive files read and send Gmail
messages and create new Google Sheets
spreadsheets and Google Documents with
the Google G Suite activity package
what are selectors and wildcards in
uipath
wild cards are the symbols that enable
you to replace 0 or multiple characters
in a string this can be quite useful
when dealing with dynamically changing
attributes in a selector
selectors uipath Studio uses what we
call selectors this store the attributes
of graphical user interface element and
its parents in the shape of an XML
fragment the selector AIDS in the
automatic generation of the selection by
utilizing wildcards
what is a machine explain standard
machine and machine template
the machine page allows you to provision
and manages machines to use them to
register robots with orchestrator
it displays the types of machine that we
currently in use it enables you to
design your machine with the standard or
template
standard machine it should be used when
the name of the machine on which you
want to Define robots is the same every
time you connect to it you define the
machine once and then you can connect to
as many robots as you want from the
robots page
machine template it should be used
whenever the name of the machine on
which you want to Define robot changes
you represent this entity once and then
you use a unique active directory
username to connect to any number of
attended floating robots
explain delay do if and switch
activities in uipath
the delay activity allows you to pause
the automation for a specified amount of
time
this activity is beneficial in projects
that require precise timing such as
waiting for a specific application to
start or for some information to be
processed before using it in the another
activity
to do activity allows you to run a
specific piece of automation while a
condition is met
the project exits the loop when the
specified condition is no longer
completed this activity can be used to
iterate through all the array elements
or execute a specific action multiple
times
effectivity the effectivity includes a
statement as well as two conditions if
the statement is true the first
condition is executed if the statement
is false the second condition is
executed if activities can be used to
make decision based on variable values
switch activity the switch activity
allows you to choose one of the several
options based on the value of specified
expression the switch activity uses an
integer argument by default
but you can change it in the properties
panel under the type argument list the
switch activity can be used to
categorize data based on predefined
number of cases
how to create chart in Excel
Step 1 create a new sequence go to the
uipath studio and create a new sequence
and then drag and drop the following
activities to create a chart we need to
use Excel application scope create table
activity and bar chart and pie chart
activity depending on which type of
charts you want to create
then at last after completing then run
the sequence
we will see a demo of this in the uipath
studio
how to upload a file on Drive
so create a new sequence and drag and
drop a g Suite application then inside G
Suite application drag and drop upload
file activity fill in the details and
finally run the suite let's go and see a
demo to how to create charts in Excel
file and how to upload a file on the
drive
so let's jump into the uipath studio
this is the Excel file which I have
created it has all the number of cases
in this 5 States in the year 2021 in the
month of Jan Feb March and April all
this record I have taken it from a
website called PRS india.org
so I have two sheets sheet1 and sheet 2.
so let's jump into the UI path Studio
start off with the demo we need to have
the three packages installed
one is the UI path Excel activities
package the other one is uipa gso dot
activities this activity this package is
used for Drive top load only drive then
the other package is Bala River Excel
activities this package is used for bar
graph and pie chart
so
after installing these three packages
we'll get started
so let's create a new sequence
name it as sequence
so first we'll drag and drop an Excel
application scope
so Excel application scope what it does
is it opens an Excel workbook and sets
the scope for Excel activities when this
activity is completed the specified
workbook and the Excel application are
closed when the workbook application
variable is specified in the output
workbook activities field the
spreadsheet is not closed
after this drag and drop a create table
activity
so by default we have sheet1 and
enter the range
so the range is in this Excel sheet
ranges from A1 to F5
so enter the range
for this we need to enter the file path
so we'll select the file
so we have selected the file
we have entered the
enter the table name
say number of cases
so once this much is done next we'll
drag and drop a bar chart
drop it outside the Excel application
scope and select the file path
so select the file
so select the file select this cell
range that is the same range what we had
entered earlier
K1 to S5
so one set is the 50 chart title
say cases
and you can select the chart type
bar stack 3D clustered 3D style whatever
is required
for now we'll select bar cluster
we have many other options to explore
data label type
will keep it in
show value so that it shows the value
and select show value
if you want to show percentage you can
select percentage
we'll select show Legend
and size
you can vary the size accordingly how
much hour you want so I'll keep the size
as
to 350.
you can change the width
so the bar chart is done
and you can enter the sheet which sheet
are you using so it's sheet1
so we will drag and drop pie chart
select the file
similarly enter the options here
enter the cell range
the same range
A1 is to F5
show percent will show value
show Legend
select show value
and select the sheet which you want
we'll select the sheet to
so done so we have computed till here
next we need to upload this on the
Google Drive so we'll select this option
upload file
select the file
you have selected the file so select the
destination folder
for that
go to your Google Drive account
so we will go there
so in my drive I have created a folder
called Excel automation
so I'll copy this URL
till here not the entire
talk to this
and go to your UI path studio and paste
it in the destination folder
this is a double quotes
then create a variable and
create a variable as file
oops there is an error
oh we have forgotten to use a g Suite
application
this can be only used inside our G Suite
so drag and drop a g Suite application
and inside G Suite application
you will find this so the error is
called
so we'll run the file now
we'll save it
and run
you can see the file is getting
run
so the execution is ended we will
navigate to the drive
so here you can see the file is
successfully uploaded we'll open the
file
it's working on the graph
here you go here you can see the bar
graph
for the sheet1 with the values
number of values and each statewise and
for Sheet 2 we created a pie chart so
here we go here you can see the question
so with that we have come to the end of
the RPA UI path full course tutorial if
you enjoyed watching it make sure to hit
the Subscribe button and press the Bell
icon to never miss an update thank you
so much for being here watch out for
more videos from us until then keep
learning and stay tuned to Simply learn